changement de l'âge de départ qui sera
de 65 ans pour les générations soit de
1965 et 1967 et 67 ans pardon pour la
génération 2000 2005 qui évidemment
c'est la source de toutes les injustices
selon que vous ayez commencé tôt ou tard
un allongement de la durée de cotisation
pour les assurés n'ayant pas fait de
longues études ne jurait qu'il commence
à travailler à 20 ans devra cotiser 45
ans contre 43 ans aujourd'hui même 47
ans pour un assuré né en 2005 il faut
savoir évidemment que cela entraîne des
conséquences et hp vous entraîne des
conséquences tout à fait différente pour
les 25 francs % de français qui sont
dans le haut du niveau de revenu qui ont
en moyenne 23 ans de retraite évidemment
voulu retirer un an ça moins de
conséquences quand vous retirez un an
pour les 25 % de français qui sont les
plus modestes et qui eux vivent en
général douze ans à la retraite
et puis dernière conséquence d'un
montant de pension soumis aux aléas des
valeurs du point
à l'acquisition comme à la liquidation
et qui est évidemment très dépendant de
la seule règle d'or qui vaille qui est
celle de l' équilibre de l'equilibre
financer globalement le système a deux
conséquences
reculer l'âge de départ effectif à la
retraite pour ceux qui auront à partir
des années 2005 à koné de l'ensemble de
la retraite trois ans de plus
et puis une baisse très significative du
taux de remplacement de l'ordre de 20 à
30 points par rapport à la situation
actuelle
donc nous sommes bien dans une forme de
régression par rapport à ce que nous
observons aujourd'hui de celles et de
ceux qui partent à la retraite
[Musique]
la parole le président jacques hojlo
chers collègues bonjour à toutes et à
tous à travers cet amendement vous
supprimez un animé à qui est un simple
anilha de coordination qui a pour but
d'éviter que les assurés du système
universel se retrouve dans un double
régime d'affiliation à l'assurance
vieillesse
cette coordination un rédactionnel n'a
pas vocation à être supprimées aussi ce
sera un avis défavorable jour merci
merci monsieur le ministre
m'est avis que le rapporteur monsieur le
président je me revois l'amendement qui
est pour contre rejeté
monsieur vélo pour le 24 1933 vous avez
la parole oui merci pour prolonger le
propos que j'ai eu sur l'amendement
premier évidemment c'est un amendement
prise de parole qui permet de dérouler
un certain nombre d'éléments et de dire
ce qu'est la réforme
lorsque nous posons la question savoir
ce qu'est une carrière complète
évidemment ça ne vaut que pour le
minimum de pension à 85% du smic en 2037
et le ministre nous a dit c'est 516 mois
pour valider un mois il faudra avoir
cotisé est l'équivalent de 50 heures
smic 50 heures smic ce qui pose la
question de savoir si en effet on se
crée bien les droits dès la première
heure ou à partir de 50 heures mais il
faudrait ajouter pour être complet à
condition d'atteindre l'équilibré nage
d'équilibré 65 ans en 2037 de 67 ans
pour la génération 2005
sinon évidemment pas de minima du tout
est juste ces points assortis d'un malus
même quand on aura cotisé 43 ans par
ailleurs dire ce que ça a été évoqué
dans les propos on va prendre en compte
les jobs étudiants
c'est vrai mais c'était également déjà
le cas aujourd'hui
de même que le temps très partiel est
déjà pris en compte trois heures par
semaine permet de valider un trimestre à
moi l'été c'est un trimestre 10 heures
par semaine ces trois trimestres et il
est vrai que dans le nouveau système
quand on sera à moins de trois heures ça
donnera quelques points mais ce qu'il
faut dire aussi c'est que dans le
système actuel à un étudiant qui
travaille 600 heures dans l'année se
voit valider une année pleine alors que
dans le nouveau système avec le même
temps d'activité et bien il ne se fera
valider que 37 % d'une année pleine ce
qui évidemment n'est pas un progrès ce
que le gouvernement prétend donner d'une
main en réalité leur prend toujours de
l'autre
merci mais je dois porter
alors j'ai du mal à comprendre l'exposé
par rapport à l'amendement
ce que la linaf vous supprimez fait que
les contractuels de droit public ne
pourront pas être dans un système
universel c'est cela que c'est un avis
défavorable bien évidemment on monsieur
ministre même avec deux rapporteurs
choisi des images de la ville vous avez
la parole monsieur vélo
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
soutenir l'argumentation qui a été
développé par boris sallaud pourquoi
parce que en réalité nous savons bien
qu'il va y avoir un certain nombre de
carrières qui qui vont effectivement
empruntés à différents itinéraires et
donc y compris on va pouvoir faire des
passages dans différents secteurs et
d'autre part il me semble que la formule
que vous proposez et bien va porter
atteinte gravement à celles et ceux qui
vont avoir des parcours discontinues la
démonstration en a été faite hier et
vous n'avez pas su apporter la preuve du
contraire et donc nous voulons nous
protéger un maximum de femmes et
d'hommes de ce mauvais projet qui est le
vôtre
donc c'est pour cette raison j'imagine
moins chers collègues boris vallot que
vous souhaitez les préserver les sortir
du dispositif qui nous est ici proposée
merci mais la parole oui tout simplement
pour prolonger les discussions et le
décryptage s'agissant des carrières
longues prières le président de la
république lequel on veut dire qu'on
pourrait toujours partir à 60 ans c'est
vraiment pour toujours partir avec 67
ans l'âge de la décote sera baissé de 2
ans mais ça signifie qu'on pourra partir
à 67 ans avec une décote de 2 ans c'est
à dire deux fois 5 % 10 %
en revanche pour rejoindre la surcote là
il n'ya pas d'abaissement de l'âge
équipe qui ressort à 64 ans nous voyez
que il ya une régression par rapport à
ce qui est donné aujourd'hui monsieur
petit
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
rappeler deux choses d'abord un
trimestre ça n'a jamais nourri personnes
donc effectivement on peut avoir un
trimestre à 3 heures mais je rappelle
qu'il ya deux systèmes aujourd'hui il ya
deux paramètres qui ceux qui sont
complètement séparés
c'est à dire qu'on peut une fois qu'on a
c'est trimestre on ne sait pas combien
on a donc non seulement on valide plus
tôt mais en plus on a déjà des points
c'est à dire qu'on a déjà quelque chose
de ce nom et trébuchants et deuxièmement
je vais faire le joint le joint avec ce
qu'on a hâte et avec la discussion
d'hier soit je suis surpris quand même
sur les nombreux calculs qu'on nous
donne et les calculs de gérard et de
jacqueline hier vous avez proposé un
amendement qui proposait de maintenir le
taux de remplacement si nécessaire en
augmentant le salaire
je répète voulait maintenir le taux de
remplacement si nécessaire en augmentant
le salaire jeu c'est écrit dans le cc
les deux derniers amendements de la
soirée d'hier
je pense qu il faut qu'on se mette bien
au clair il faut qu'on reprenne nos
débats sur ce que veut le dire les les
données mathématiques c'est ça ne marche
pas ce qu'on peut pas maintenir un taux
de remplacement nous comptons à ce à
l'heure où vous lisez les deux hommes
ont dit hier soir n'aura l'occasion d'y
revenir je mets deux voies l'amendement
défaveur commission gouvernement qui y
est pour quand je t'ai le 9900 sont très
pas défendu le 9656 n'est pas défendu le
9553 n'est pas défendu 2
madame ménard le 3899 défavorable
commission défavorable gouvernement je
mets deux voies qui est pour contre je
t'ai 9939 pas défendu 9288 pas défendu
monsieur le président woerth de 27000 ou
madame bello monsieur monsieur woerth
oui il s'agit de il s'agit de l'ircantec
il s'agit de bien clarifier les choses
en ce qui concerne la fonction publique
sommes favorables à un régime universel
socle on a déjà indiqué des régimes
complémentaires au dessus et nous sommes
favorables pour les salariés un régime
choc qui soit cohérent et mise en
cohérence et fusionné avec celui des
fonctionnaires nous pensons depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs dans l'article 16
de la loi de 2010 il était prévu un
régime universel à point ce qu'on
entendait par universel c'était fusion
public privé était pas les caisses
autonomes c'était la fusion du public et
du privé nous sommes favorables et dans
la fusion du public et du privé il ya
des facto la suppression des régimes
spéciaux donc des points de recouvrement
sur des parties très très importante
ce que nous avons déjà discuté avec le
avec le ministre et donc nous souhaitons
qui est une fusion complète des régimes
public et des régimes privés au travers
du régime socle et au travers d'un
régime complémentaire qui vaudrait pour
le public et qui vaudrait pour le privé
c'est le sens de cet amendement
[Musique]
1000mercis dans le système universel
il n'y aura plus de distinction entre
régimes de base et régimes
complémentaires par ailleurs dans
l'amendement que vous vous présentez
vous écraser
la coordination qui est permise par cet
amendement et vous visez qui vise les
agents nés avant 75 aussi ce sera un
avis défavorable ministre dit non même
avis monsieur de la rive il souhaitait
exprimer
pado oui merci monsieur le président je
suis pas très bien compris exactement à
quoi faisait référence notre notre
collègue petit bon moi je pensais plutôt
le texte qu'il faut réécrire que nos
amendements mais cela étant dit en
revanche c'est ce que vous faites
le mécanisme que vous avez indiquée
notamment pour les enseignants c'est une
partie de ce que vous proposez et donc
c'est le dévoilement là d'un problème
majeur dans le coeur du système coeur du
réacteur
vous êtes en train de colmater de tous
les côtés pour essayer d'éviter que ça
fuit et que ça me donne les résultats
trop catastrophique mais je crains qu'il
soit catastrophique tout de même
monsieur manigod jeu betty est prêt oui
merci monsieur le président mon petit
question fallait rapporter en général et
le ministre à ce stade à la fin de
l'article 3 vous dites que le taux de
rendement entre notre reste pour tous
les cas type en fait à 5 5 % et ce taux
fait partie notamment de vos arguments
de vente de la réforme
or la valeur d'acquisition du point ne
progressera de 2025 à 2045 en pouvoir
d'achat que la moitié de la hausse de
pouvoir d'achat du salaire moyen
c'est en partie ce qui ressort de votre
étude d'impact page 196 qui précise que
la valeur d'acquisition sera de 2025 à
2042 indexés sur une pondération entre
l'inflation et le salaire moyen par tête
soit en 17 ans
si le salaire moyen progresse de 1 3%
par an en pouvoir d'achat et que
l'indexation pondérés en pouvoir d'achat
et de 0 65 % par an une perte nette de
pouvoir d'achat pour tous ceux qui
seront concernés pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur ce point monsieur petit
vous avez la parole oui je précise nous
nous avons dit que nous voulions
garantir ou rattraper un niveau de
pension en augmentant les rémunérations
dans les amendements que nous avons
étudié hier je maintiens vous vouliez
maintenir un taux de remplacement
vous pouvez pas maintenir un taux de
remplacement en augmentant les pins mais
c'est pas moi qui mélange tout comment
vous enfin c'est une règle de 3 1 je
dirais si si vous augmentez la
rémunération bon j'ai terminé monsieur
le président merci madame du bien oui
merci monsieur le président sur ce sujet
de l'ircantec
il y a également sa gère également les
retraites des élus locaux maires
conseillers départementaux conseils
régionaux pardon et donc je voulais
savoir si aujourd'hui c'est déjà un
système de points est ce que l'élu local
qui a une activité salariée donc qu'il y
a qu'ils se rassurent un régime par
points
au travers de son activité salariée
est-ce que les points acquis durant la
même période de son activité les
salariés seront cumulables et se
rajoutent auront en fait au nombre de
points pour à terme le calcul de sa
retraite permet de rajouter quelque
chose puisque beaucoup ont parlé
notamment de valeur de remplacement
d'éléments de cette nature qui ont ce
début de séance
on peut peut-être poser un certain
nombre de 2 points et 1 ce qui concerne
la valeur de remplacement
je voudrais revenir à ce qu'a dit la
cour des comptes sur la jirs que arrco
puisque c'est comme d'actualité elle a
dit que on allie en analysant la façon
dont la valeur d'achat du point a évolué
plus rapidement que sa valeur de service
donc on fait bien la différence entre
valeur d'achat et valeur de 2 services
la cour a montré que le rendement du
régime a diminué passant de 6 points 56
% en 2015 à 5 99% en 2018 donc il ya une
perte de valeur du point au travers même
d'une évolution différenciée de la
valeur de service et de la valeur
d'achat
il est noter et c'est pas quelque chose
de théorique c'est ce dont on peut se
c'est ce qui est le cas exactement sur
les régimes complémentaires agirc arrco
donc on peut toujours parler de valeur
de rendement etc
on peut dire que l'on sait de quoi il
s'agit lorsqu'on a des points ces deux
valeurs donc on a déjà évoqué lors des
discussions précédentes et convoquera
lorsqu on n'évoquera les points est un
est absolument document clé dans le
régime que vous voulez créer il faut
donc bien connecté ces deux valeurs si
vous ne voulez pas de perte de rendement
pour les retraites futures
j'aimais de voix l'amendement 27 1354
qui est pour contre rejeté
je me revois l'article 3 qui pour
l'adoption de l'article 3 contre
l'article 3 est adopté nous venons à
l'article 4 madame
[Musique]
je vois pas des messieurs viry joué
déprimé
verdict 4 merci monsieur président
effectivement quelques observations sur
l'article 4 et peut-être en a moins a
préalablement observé que notre rythme
de travail est soutenu
il me paraît conforme aux modes de nos
travaux habituels au rythme d'examen des
abonnements ce dont je me félicite
j'avais pu effectivement hier soir
exprimé un avis par rapport à l'article
3 je suis ravi qu'on rentre dès à
présent dans l'article 4
article 4 qui est important puisqu'il
procède à l'intégration des travailleurs
indépendants dans le champ du système
universel les mêmes règles de calcul des
droits à la retraite pour tous les
travailleurs indépendants on en a parlé
depuis depuis une semaine c'est votre
système s'était pas forcément le note
nous avons une vraie divergence de vue
sur la solution adaptée nous ce qui nous
préoccupe et j'espère que les
amendements nous permettront d'aller
chercher les réponses que nous que nous
voulons sur ce sujet sur votre solution
qui nous paraît baroque et et inefficace
quel coût quel coup cela va représenter
quelque où cela va représenter parce que
il ya forcément un impact économique et
budgétaire et cela nous paraît
totalement masqué en l'état et on ne
peut pas prendre une décision sans
savoir quelle sera les conséquences
financières et surtout quelle pourrait
être la l'harmonie entre ceux nés avant
75 et ceux qui sont nés après 75 qui
vont être automatiquement intégrés pour
nous il ya effectivement des inconnus
des interrogations avec deux situations
qui vont donc coexister
durant la phase de transition avec une
couverture commune au risque vieillesse
invalidité pour certains avec une
couverture distingue de ces deux risques
entre le risque vieillesse qui va
dépendre d'une bronche et le risque à
valider des décès qui va dépendre des
anciens régimes tout cela nous paraît
hasardeuse inquiétant pour les assurés
nous espérons fortement que les débats
dans relatif à l'article 4 par rapport
aux amandes
mettront d'y voir plus clair monsieur
dufrègne à la parole
puis madame oui monsieur le président
effectivement nous abordons à l'article
4 l'épineuse question de la fusion dans
votre système universel des régimes
autonome des travailleurs indépendants
et libéraux et de leurs caisses
complémentaires épineuse en effet car
dans de nombreux cas cette fusion fera
des perdants
que ce soit en termes de cotisations ou
en termes de prestations certaines
catégories d'indépendants subiront un
des douze un doublement de leur
cotisation dans le cadre du système
universel sans y gagner en termes de
prestations plusieurs professions sont
également très opposés à ce texte car
elles perdront la gestion de leur régime
autonome ou de leur caisse
complémentaire est l'occasion nous est
donnée ici de revenir à ce qui vous
oppose aux avocats qui je le rappelle
sont engagés dans une mobilisation
historique sans précédent que vous
reproche-t-il les avocats et les avocats
de ce pays s'insurge contre votre
volonté d'instaurer une retraite minimum
portait 1000 euros contre 1400 euros
aujourd'hui
ils s'insurgent contre l'augmentation du
taux de cotisation qui s'il est appliqué
verra les plus petits cabinets être
durement pénalisé c'est le cas dans mon
département puisque ils verront ce taux
passer de 14 à 28 % quand dans le même
temps les gros cabinets seront amenés à
payer moins et bien si c'est faux vous
le dis vous démontrer mais c'est pas ce
qu'ils disent une fois encore une fois
encore une fois encore c'est pas plus
faut que ce que disait monsieur petit
tout à l'heure une fois encore vous
déroulez une politique de classe au
service des plus puissants et ça c'est
pas nouveau et ce au grand dam des plus
démunis puisque en pénalisant les petits
cabinets vous touché durement les
populations les plus fragiles qui
bénéficient de l'aide juridictionnelle
au fond vous faites ici portée aux seuls
avocats les caprices d'une politique et
d'une réforme qui dessert une profession
pourtant peu habitués à manifester de la
sorte
sachez que
nous les soutenons et nous restons
déterminés à ce que cette mauvaise
réforme ne touche pas des femmes et des
hommes si utile au bon fonctionnement de
notre république
merci monsieur le président je fais
suite à monsieur dufrègne et
effectivement ce que je souhaite
préciser avant tout c'est que tout le
monde est utile dans notre société
monsieur dufrègne les invocations 65000
personnes sur 60 millions je pense qu'il
ya tout un tas d'autres professionnels
qui sont utiles donc merci de penser à
eux
et justement c'est justement cet article
4 nous sommes très fiers de le porter
parce que justement cet article iv dit
que l'ensemble des professions
indépendantes des artisans des
commerçants des professions libérales
vont être intégrés dans ce système
universel et c'est justement pour eux
beaucoup plus de lisibilité et surtout
chers collègues beaucoup plus de
protection
combien d'artisans et de commerçants
souhaitent intégrer ce régime ils sont
absolument gagnant de la même manière
pour les professions libérales
la plupart sont absolument gagnante
lorsque l'on intègre ce système puisque
il n'y a pas de surcoût est au contraire
on accède à une revendication de longue
date qui est la simplification de
l'assiette sociale donc moi ce que je
souhaite à dire à ces artisans à ces
commerçants à ces professions libérales
c'est justement aujourd'hui nous sommes
nous simplifions l'assiette sociale ce
qui est votre revendication depuis très
longtemps et faisant cela nous vous
permettons également d'être mieux
couverts et d'avoir plus de droits pour
la retraite
est ce un coup absolument nulle puisque
justement les cotisations en plus sont
compensées par les abaissements de
l'assiette sociale donc je pense
justement que tous l'ensemble de ces
professionnels sont gagnants et vont
pouvoir avoir de nouveaux droits à la
retraite et être mieux protégés à la
retraite
grâce à cette réforme donc artisans
commerçants professions indépendantes
professions libérales
donc nous sommes absolument fier de cet
article
monsieur isaac signé la parole monsieur
isaac sybille est la parole
merci monsieur le président oui non à
l'occasion parti c'est important et
c'est un petit peu c'est disent
effectivement le haut-commissaire de le
voir on n'est pas seulement dans une
réforme du système des retraites ont un
système de réforme du système un peu
global de notre système le notre système
social
et c'est vrai que les livres les
professions libérales et professions
indépendantes
on ne part les avocats on parle beaucoup
de professions libérales c'est pas
tellement la réforme des retraites qui
fragilise c'est le système même
dépression indépendante donc ce qui va
réfléchir dans les semaines qui arrivent
c'est voir comment ce qu'on renforce le
modèle libéral nos sociétés et je suis
très content que sur l'ensemble de ces
bancs aussi bien qu'à droite qu'à gauche
qu'on défende ce modèle libéral de
professions indépendantes
oui elle donc monsieur coquerel cet
article quatre concernent effectivement
les travailleuses et travailleurs
indépendants qui rejoindrait ainsi le
régime dit universel
pour notre part nous rejetons ces
dispositions alors non pas qu'on soit
contre une application disposition et
équitablement uniforme en matière de
pensions de retraite
mais la manière encore une fois dont
c'est fait on sait proposer évidemment
pose problème puisque on ignore très
souvent les spécificités des régimes
applicables aux libéraux qui sont aux
fruits j'allais dire d'accord de
construction historique alors on la cité
on y reviendra plus tard dans le débat
hier la question des avocats qui par
cette augmentation à 28 % pour les plus
fragiles d'entre eux seraient menacés de
disparition
mais je note que en réalité pour toutes
les professions libérales qui
manifestaient n'y a pas si longtemps il
y avait les médecins il y avait divers
profession c'est un grand saut dans le
vide et c'est d'autant plus un grand
saut dans le vide
c'est que si pour ma part discuter de
l'article 4 me convient on s'aperçoit
que la modification des taux
et assiettes des cotisations on en parle
à l'article 21 et à l'article 21e rang
voie d ordonnance donc une fois de plus
on est en train de légiférer pour des
des millions de nos concitoyens sur
quelque chose qui sera ensuite défini
par le gouvernement et non pas pour
l'assemblée si vous cette raison que
nous nous opposerons à cet article 4 une
des raisons merci voilà tous les groupes
qui le souhaitaient ont pu s'exprimer
nous en revenons donc aux amendements et
j'informe me semblait que sur le 227
amendement de suppression de l'article
et sur les amendements identiques je
suis saisi par le groupe l'est
républicain et les groupes de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine d'une demande
de scrutin public de scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale et sur cet amendement 227 qui
le défend des pendus le 270 pas défendu
même madame antoine pour le 343 devait
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur mini cet article prévoit donc
l'application du système universel de
retraite aux travailleurs indépendants
je crois que ce qu'il faut bien voir et
on vous l'a dit et on vous le redit
encore c'est que ont adhéré des régimes
qui sont à l' équilibre des régimes qui
sont pérennes
donc on ne voit pas vu les spécificités
qui sont présentés par les travailleurs
indépendants pourquoi vous voulez
absolument les mettre dans ce régime
universel et si vous comparez avec les
autres pays les libéraux ils ont des
régimes autonomes ils ont des régimes
autonomes parce que c'est leur
indépendance et donc en l'espèce en
voulant doubler leur taux de cotisation
avec des retraites qui seront à l'égal
ou voir même moindre que ce qui est
prévu à l'heure actuelle vous à les
pénaliser
les indépendants et c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous nous vous demandons de
supprimer cet article
merci monsieur minot pour le 397 vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président effectivement je vais
reprendre quelques propos de ma collègue
antoine qui propose de supprimer cet
article puisque le régime d'assurance
vieillesse notamment des avocats mais
aussi des de certaines professions
libérales sont autonomes et
bénéficiaires ce projet de loi propose
pourtant de supprimer donc l'intention
de vouloir mettre sur pied d'égalité et
toutes les professions
concernant la retraite pourrait être
comprise si elle ne mettait pas
notamment en péril la survie de
certaines d'entre elles donc en effet en
intégrant à l'assurance vieillesse des
avocats au système universel ceux ci
vont voir dans le même temps leur taux
de cotisation doublé passant de 14 %
actuellement à 28 % avec le nouveau
système
donc ça représente un risque un risque
financier majeur pour les petits
cabinets notamment et une fille née une
mise en danger de l'accès au droit donc
cet amendement propose de supprimer
l'article 4 merci pour le 80 primeurs
merci monsieur le président oui
effectivement cet article 4 pose
quelques questions auxquelles nous
allons toujours nous n'avons toujours
pas eu les réponses mais quand j'entends
les éléments de langage du groupe la
république en marche
vous ne pouvez pas m'empêcher de sourire
parce que la réalité bien sûr que
certaines professions indépendantes vont
par ce mécanisme bénéficier d'un minimum
retraite un peu plus intéressant qu'il
ne le faut nos réputés en dhr attendez
attendez j'ai pas punis mais ouais oui
c'est ça vous merci monsieur cazeneuve
mais la contrepartie c'est une infime
c'est une infime partie des professions
libérales
un des professions indépendantes
notamment les artisans et les
commerçants
enfin
il faudra pas oublier qu'ils vont la
côte ils vont la payer leurs retraites
ce serait pas le système qui va leur
offrir c'est bien eux qui vont la payer
avec un doublement des cotisations donc
je vois pas d'une part où se trouve le
système
je crois sincèrement que pour payer
justement les cotisations retraite dans
le régime où vous les affiliés certains
vont avoir de vraies difficultés
je pense à tous les instants des
indépendants comme les coiffeurs ce type
de profession mais pour les professions
libérales toutes celles qui sont aussi
considérés comme des indépendants
on a parlé beaucoup des avocats hier moi
je pense aux experts comptables les
médecins tout toutes les spécialités de
médecine qu'il s'agisse des podologues
des kinésithérapeutes toutes ces
professions la non seulement vous les
ponctionner en doublant leur taux de
cotisation mais vous allez leur garantir
un minimum retraite qui sera bien
inférieur à celui qu'il pouvait à auquel
il pouvait prétendre ce qui veut dire
que pour augmenter le niveau de retraite
d'une toute petite partie celle que vous
avez applaudi vous à les affaiblir
toutes les autres catégories au nom d'un
dogme parce que vous voulez
impérativement passer par une retraite à
points d'ailleurs le meilleur exemple
qui vient problème c'est que vous avez
été obligé par le biais d'un amendement
du gouvernement de réduire l'assiette de
csg pour l'être les cotisations à la csg
de réduire l'assiette c'est là où vous
avez compris qu'il y avait quand même un
problème dans votre dispositif
et là je ne vous applaudit pas merci
donc il faut qu'on vient de supprimer
cet article qu'un le 948 monsieur vélo
oui merci du président bon s'agissant
des indépendants on a une difficulté que
l'on continue de souligner pour les
indépendants dont les cotisations entre
1 et 3 passes on a cotisé moins que les
salariés ça fait que le taux de
rendement réel c'est-à-dire qui
additionne la part contributive et non
contributive et substantiellement
différentes et ça nous paraît constituer
une rupture une rupture d'égalité majeur
puisque entre 20 et 3 passes c'est un
taux de 12 94 % avec 2 81 points de
parts non contributives ce qui est en
proportion beaucoup plus important et
donc évidemment le taux de rendement
réel entre les salariés et les
indépendants et substantiellement
différent et puis par ailleurs ça a été
évoqué il nous avons une crainte qui est
une crainte forte
s'agissant de l'assiette de la csg qui
va être rouge et pour les indépendants
et pas pour les salariés et en dépit de
ce qu'a dit le conseil d'état ça reste
une contribution de toutes natures et
nous craignons que la jurisprudence
constante du conseil constitutionnel ait
vocation à s'appliquer et que au
lendemain de deux votes de l'adoption de
cette loi si ça devant être la funeste
conclusion est bien une censure du
conseil constitutionnel viennent
totalement perturbé les promesses qui
ont été formulées par par le
gouvernement à leur endroit
madame ménard pour le 3933 oui merci
monsieur le président également un
amendement de suppression de cet article
4 qui a pour objectif donc d'intégrer au
régime universel de retraite les
travailleurs indépendants que sont les
artisans les commerçants et les
professionnels libéraux alors que leurs
régimes indépendants et autonomes n'ont
jamais coûté un euro au contribuable
depuis leur création ces régimes
autonome permettent de prendre en compte
les spécificités de ces plus de ces
professions et introduisent de la
souplesse dans la définition des règles
qui les régissent sans que cela coûte
encore une fois un seul euro à la
sécurité sociale
ils sont à l'équilibré le régime
autonome des avocats par exemple et en
particulier
reverse chaque année près de 100
millions d'euros au régime général
le gouvernement s'apprête à l'or
confisqué les deux milliards d'euros de
réserves qu'ils ont rassemblées par
leurs efforts un libéral paye 100 % de
sa cotisation retraite
il est donc nécessaire de moduler son
taux de cotisation en fonction des
caractéristiques de sa profession et on
voulant imposer un même taux de
cotisation à tous
vous allez fortement pénalisé certaines
professions alors que rien ne le
justifie en intégrant l'assurance
vieillesse des libéraux au système
universel ceux ci vont voir dans le même
temps leur taux de cotisation doublé
passant de 14 % actuellement à 28 % avec
le nouveau système sans de surcroît la
certitude d'avoir un même niveau de
pension et pour les avocats
cette intégration est ni plus ni moins
qu'un impôt déguisé puisque elle
reviendra alors faire financer les
régimes aujourd'hui déficitaires
d'autres professions à commencer par les
régimes spéciaux du secteur public dont
les avantages ne sont plus financés et
grèvent le budget de l'état
je vous remercie monsieur le président
merci nous en venons à la série des 1600
de mal à moteur je vais la parole
l'amendement de suppression
oui c'est un amendement de suppression
que nous soutenons puisque l'inclusion
des indépendants dans le régime général
pose de très nombreux problèmes je pense
pour commencer déjà à l'étape de
transition puisqu'il va y avoir un
lissage sur 15 ans nous dit le projet de
loi sans qu'on y voit tout à fait clair
et la hausse des cotisations retraites
devra être compensée nous dit-on par une
baisse de la csg mais c'est pas du tout
le même
les mêmes 15 c'est à dire qu'on va
déposséder la sécurité sociale d'un
certain nombre de moyens et on va
appauvrir des catégories et celles qui
vont être parmi elles les plus touchées
impact sur le système de santé par
exemple ou sur le système juridique est
par ailleurs il est prévu une sorte de
vol de vol du siècle comme disent les
syndicats de médecins puisque les
réserves qui ont été accumulées par par
les professions qui ont un système
autonome vont servir à payer la
transition ce sont plus de 2 milliards
d'euros qui sont dans les caisses
d'avocats et pour les caisses des
médecins ses 7,7
lien ce qui est tout à fait considérable
et pour les usagers que nous sommes
il va y avoir une répercussion je vais
vous parler de la seine saint denis qui
me préoccupe puisque en seine saint
denis vous savez monsieur le ministre
que 70% de la population est éligible à
l'aide juridique et qu'avec cette hausse
des cotisations qui va donc doubler pour
passer à 28 % le risque c'est que 40%
des cabinets ferme et ce sont ceux qui
justement s'occupe de l'aide juridique
et des populations qui sont les plus
fragiles
par ailleurs vous aurez au total une
baisse drastique des pensions pour ces
professions je pense par exemple aux
médecins qui ont anticipé qu'en 2050 ce
qu'ils toucheront dans le régime général
dans votre système fera qu' il y aura
une baisse de l'ordre de 30% et ce qui
est évident c'est que pour ceux qui le
pourront ils vont aller dans le système
d'épargne-retraite c'est à dire qu'ils
vont recourir à de la capitalisation
donc on a là quelque part la
quintessence de la catastrophe annoncée
par votre patron votre système
merci alors nous en venons au 11 1884
qui est défendu puis au 23 1809 bové la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre les professions libérales les
commerçants les artisans seront les
grands perdants de votre projet
d'universalité de leur retraite alors
même que ces professionnels ont fait le
choix de l'indépendance de leur activité
et donc et donc d'en assurer toutes les
conséquences
mais pas celle de voir doubler leurs
cotisations qui va pénaliser leur
pouvoir d'achat
durant leur activité sans pour autant
leur assurer une retraite décente cela a
été démontré brillamment par mes
collègues notamment marie christine
dalloz les commerçants subissent depuis
de nombreux mois des difficultés
économiques
vous le savez les différents mouvements
qui se sont succédé ont déjà fortement
fragilisé leur trésorerie
ce système que vous prétendez équitable
tir au contraire nos professions
libérales vers le bas aussi convient-il
de supprimer cet article 4 je vous
remercie
merci monsieur viry pour le 24 1926
merci monsieur faisons par rapport à cet
article 4 il y avait effectivement des
amendements de suppression
j'observe je l'avais fait la semaine
dernière qu'un amendement déposé par
madame le pen et que ce n'est pas rien
de son groupe n'a pas été défendu ce
devient monnaie courante je voulais
faire cette observation nous concernant
nous concernant nous considérons que les
professions libérales et travailleurs
indépendants ce sont des acteurs
économiques avant toute chose des
acteurs économiques qui répondent à des
particularités qui répondent à des
exigences de modèle économique
et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle ils bénéficient notamment en
termes de protection sociale et de
retraite d'un régime spécifique
il ne dépend de personne ils n'ont pas
de lien de subordination
c'est la raison pour laquelle leurs
propres caisses sont gérés par eux mêmes
avec beaucoup de sagesse avec beaucoup
de prévoyance qui leur permet d'assurer
une pérennité
c'est la raison pour laquelle à mon avis
à mon avis il faut supprimer cet article
4 mais permettez moi permettez moi
peut-être une observation quelque peu
plus large
ces professions libérales on a beaucoup
parlé de certaines mais que ce soit les
orthophonistes les infirmiers et
beaucoup d'autres ils ont des craintes
majeures par rapport à ce que vous
leur proposer il me paraît qu'en matière
de système de retraite il soit
nécessaire effectivement de continuer
les étapes successives engagé depuis les
années 90 depuis la première décennie
des années 2000 qui ont permis de
consolider notre système de retraites
pour le pérenniser et assurer à terme le
paiement des pensions qu'on débatte
pendant ce quinquennat du système de
retraite il cela nous paraît nécessaire
c'était papa une étape complémentaire
qu'il fallait qu'il fallait le faire
le sujet c'est que vous mettez
totalement sûr sur la table fracassé
vous fracassez l'existant et un système
de retraites ne peut aboutir que si la
légitimité populaire que s'il ya une
forme d'un sentiment de la population
par rapport à ce que vous voulez leur
proposer par rapport à l'offre de
services moi il me paraît que au delà du
système sur lequel nous avons des points
de divergence majeure dont nous
contestons un certain nombre de deux
finalités d'orientation de mise en
oeuvre
il me paraît très hasardeuse quand on
voit l'état du pays
quand on voit la fragilité morale de ce
pays quand on voit un certain nombre
d'éléments qui devraient nous appeler à
de la vigilance démocratique
il me paraît effectivement hasardeux de
vouloir passer en force de vouloir coûte
que coûte
alors qu'on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas d'
adhésion majoritaire à votre système
il me paraît hasardeux de le faire je le
dis parce que s'il ya manifestement une
commande et rage des professionnels qui
le refusent ce sont tous les
travailleurs indépendants mais ça
concerne beaucoup d'autres salariés et
de travers dans ce pays et ce faisant et
ce faisant vous prenez un risque
probablement que votre loi sera adapté
on verra sous quel format on pourrait en
débattre au très longuement mais il
s'agit pas de poser un nouveau cadre
législatif
il faut s'assurer que dans son
application ça va se faire aisément
il faut s'assurer que les conséquences
collatérales ne seront pas dramatiques
et là je conseille vous prenez un risque
il nous venons
à l'amendement monsieur que créent elles
n'ont cessé amendement du groupe gdr le
26 1745 est défendu monsieur brunet
merci monsieur le président donc
l'article 4 prévoit que le système
universel de retraite s'applique aux
travailleurs si la collègue la public en
marche tu veut s'exprimer n'a qu'à
prendre le micro ce sera beaucoup plus
simple merci madame
voilà donc le système universel de
retraite s'applique ou travailleurs
indépendants artisans commerçants et
professionnels libéraux
cet article applique donc la fusion dans
le système universel des régimes
autonome des travailleurs indépendants
et libéraux et de leurs caisses
complémentaires dans de nombreux cas
cette fusion fera des perdants que ce
soit en termes de cotisations ou en
termes de prestations tout d'abord votre
système ne peut être équitable et juste
dans la mesure où chaque secteur
d'activité a ses spécificités
il n'est est compréhensible de créer un
système universel dans la mesure où les
libéraux les fonctionnaires et des
salariés du secteur privé ne bénéficie
pas d'un même traitement
les indépendants ne profite pas des
mêmes avantages sociaux que d autres
actifs de ce fait des règles uniformiser
pour la retraite seront préjudiciables
pour les professions libérales et les
indépendants en effet ces derniers
doivent assurer des heures de travail
largement supérieur aux 35 heures établi
pour les fonctionnaires les salariés et
en matière de santé entre hot les
professions libérales ne bénéficie pas
d'un système leur garantissant la même
protection que celle accordée aux
fonctionnaires aux salariés avec votre
réforme avec certaines catégories
d'indépendants ils subiront un
doublement de leur cotisation dans le
cas du système universel 28% jusqu'au
plafond annuel de 40000 euros sans y
gagner en termes de prestations
plusieurs professions sont également
très opposés à ce texte car elles
perdront la gestion de leur régime
autonome
on a parlé beaucoup des avocats ici ou
dans leurs caisses complémentaires mais
c'est aussi les kinés les pharmaciens
les experts comptables
merci alors le 30 4314 pas défendu
madame thibodeau donc je sais tout
venant d'eux défendu et
je crois qu'on a tous passé sur ces
amendements de suppression avis de la
commission mesure à porter en réponse
merci monsieur le président à travers
cette cette série d amendements
identiques vous proposé d'exclure du
système universel
les artisans les commerçants les
professions libérales de l'entente du
nous ne partageons pas ce point de vue
pour trois points tout d'abord parce que
nous ne voyons pas ce qui justifierait
l'exception que vous que vous proposez
ce serait d'une certaine manière d'une
rupture d'égalité et nous proposons que
toutes les professions rentrer dans ce
système universel qui appuie d'ailleurs
bénéficier de l'ensemble des points de
solidarité qui seront dans ce système
universel et nous ne voyons pas pourquoi
telle ou telle profession seraient
exclus les ans la madame cher collègue
dalloz
je conçois que ce soit une différence
d'éléments de langage je pense qu'il ya
une divergence de vision programmatique
entre les républicains et en tout cas la
majorité et nous allons en débattre à
travers à travers cet article bien
entendu deuxièmement ces professions qui
vont entrer dans le régime universel et
indépendants des commerçants et
professions libérales vont bénéficier de
dispositions dérogatoires aussi bien
durant la période transitoire que durant
la période une fois que le système cible
sera mise en place
et puis enfin troisièmement bien entendu
les caisses qui gère aujourd'hui les
retraites de ces professions perdureront
demain dans le système me l'avons évoqué
d'ailleurs a à de multiples reprises
tout au long de nos débats et donc par
un système de conventions avec la cnr et
continueront à fonctionner avec
l'interlocuteur unique et à pouvoir
faire vivre au sein des professions des
dispositifs de solidarité aussi ce sera
un avis défavorable sur l'ensemble de
ces amendements de suppression de cet
article quatre jours merci monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est un
avis défavorable je voudrais quand même
profiter de ce moment défavorable oui je
parle donc fait un peu vite mais
défavorables je vais profiter de ce ce
temps les changes pour revenir sur comme
un certain nombre de contre vérités et
d'approximations qui ont pu être qu'on
peut être dit et comme c'est de façon
récurrente et non c'est pas les accords
politiques c'est vous pouvez il faut
quand même être clair on a parlé plus
d'une dizaine de fois monsieur le
président peut-être 20 x 30 x 40 x sur
le sujet des réserves
je vous ai donné les articles dans la
loi qui mentionne le fait qu' il n'y a
aucune expropriation en matière de
réserves je vous ai rappelé le discours
du premier ministre
du 11 décembre je vous ai explicité à
plusieurs reprises la position du
gouvernement sur les réserves et
pourtant monsieur le président il ya eu
au moins trois ou quatre interventions
de députés qui ont affirmé qu'ils ont
affirmé ici dans cet hémicycle que les
réserves des caisses indépendante serait
capter ce qui est faux ce qui est
matériellement faux seins et donc il est
compliqué d'avoir un débat lorsqu'on a
une succession de contre vérités et qui
sont réaffirmées c'est pas une question
d'information monsieur le président
puisque les informations déjà été donné
à plusieurs reprises ici donc il ya une
volonté d'entretenir une sorte de flou
artistique qui se compose de
contrevérités additionner alors deuxième
contre-vérité on vient de nous affirmer
on vient je vais essayé de m'exprimer
merci merci deuxième contre-vérité on
vient de nous affirmer de la même façon
on vient nous affirmer de la même façon
qu'eux il y aurait donc une augmentation
des cotisations et une baisse des
pensions
c'est faux c'est faux lorsqu'il y a dans
certaines professions libérales une
baisse des cotisations notamment chez
les médecins
c'est intéressant parce qu on a eu un
certain nombre de députés qui
connaissent bien le sujet comme le
député jean-pierre door avec qui on a pu
discuter qu'après quatre ou cinq jours
sur le sujet on voit bien que le député
de reconnaît le sujet est d'ailleurs il
n'aura jamais dit ça il a bien
conscience que les médecins ont des
niveaux de cotisation supérieure
ce qu'ils auront dans le régime
universel mais que par ailleurs le
niveau de pensions qu'ils percevront
demain ne sera pas inférieur à la baisse
qu'ils auront de leur cotisation tout
sera sera due proportion et le chlore ce
que la proportion sera même plus entre
guillemets intéressante
ils ont il le sait bien et des médecins
le savent bien
toutes les organisations
professionnelles que j'en rencontre et
le savent bien
autre contrevérité qui a tendance
peut-être à c'est parce qu'elle est
récurrente que fini par devenir une
exactitude
on peut pas en permanence dire que les
professions libérales sont tout vent
debout contre cette transformation
société c'est faux c'est faux le haut
commissaire et moi même avons rencontré
l'ensemble des organisations
professionnelles représentatives des
professions libérales et donc il est
faux de dire que les professions
libérales sont vent debout contre cette
réforme
bien sûr que la plupart du temps les
professions libérales avait une
préférence pour qu'on ce qu'on se limite
à 1 passe chez d'ailleurs dit à
plusieurs reprises aux prisons woerth
que j'entendais bien que le projet qu'il
portait ressemblait plus à celui des
professions libérales que à celui que
nous portons nous mais les professions
libérales ou aussi accusé réception du
fait que lorsqu'il y avait des
évolutions cotisations elle s'y
retrouverait au niveau de pension dans
un sens comme dans un autre
donc il faut là dessus être aussi
explicite est resté sur des éléments
objectifs vérifiables et comparables à
vis défendre à monsieur le président
alors plusieurs de raptor en réponse à
la mode on a quand même quelque chose je
n'arrive pas très bien à comprendre
monsieur le ministre c'est pourquoi elle
est pourquoi les avocats en particulier
mais pas simplement les avocats
n'entendent pas les choses de la même
manière que ce que vous nous raconter
ici bien sûr qu'ils disent que vous
allez au final pillé les caisses et
d'ailleurs la caisse va de fait
disparaître puisqu'ils vont rentrer dans
le régime général première chose
deuxièmement sur la baisse des pensions
vous ne pouvez absolument pas affirmer
qu'il n'y aura pas de baisse de pensions
comme chacune des professions artisans
commerçants professions libérales on a
vu les médecins les infirmières et bien
d'autres professions qui ont fait des
projections et qui elles disent et tous
syndicats confondus qu'il va bien y
avoir une baisse quant à la concertation
que vous affichez comment vous pouvez
expliquer que les syndicats ou hier les
avocats qui était juste devant
l'assemblée nationale et exhortait qu'il
puisse y avoir une rencontre et le
sentiment que leur voix n'est pas été
entendu et qu'il ya eu très peu d'heures
de discussions sur leur régime et sur
l'évolution des spécificités de leur
caisse leur caisse de retraite
donc je comprends pas très bien comment
vous pouvez expliquer c'est pas
simplement les députés de l'opposition
vous mettez en cause aujourd'hui ce sont
également les syndicats représentatifs
des professions en question et des
mobilisations qui dépensent même celles
et ceux qui sont syndiqués est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi ils
sont si en colère si votre système et si
vertueux est par ailleurs est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer les garanties
que vous pouvez donner notamment sur la
baisse de la csg quand vous dites on va
compenser si vous voulez compensé la
hausse qui va être bien réel puisqu'on
passe de 14 à 28 par exemple pour les
avocats et d'autres professions sont
concernés par la hausse
comment vous allez garantir le fait que
la baisse de la csg par exemple puisse
réellement compenser nous nous sommes en
désaccord avec la philosophie même c'est
à dire de déshabiller paul pour habiller
jacques ça ne nous convient pas du tout
mais il n'y a aucune garantie que cette
baisse
la csg soit durable et qu'elle compense
véritablement dont vous êtes en train de
nous raconter des sornettes
absolument merci j'ai poussé la parole
si monsieur le président jean temps
plusieurs éléments c'est de les
reprendre dans l'ordre sur le côté
universel
la france est championne du monde de
l'exception de la niche du village
gaulois on veut être en france ne jamais
vraiment être comme les autres le
principe même de ceux de ce philosophie
de projets de retraite c'est la
solidarité
on est tous solidaires les uns avec les
autres
pourquoi les routiers sa solitaire des
routiers les avocats des avocats les
mineurs des mineurs et pourquoi mineurs
de ces passionnés aérien routier et un
avocat avec un mineur donc le principe
même justement c'est de retrouver une en
force
une solidarité qui fait que lorsque
quelqu'un en france un citoyen une
profession est en difficulté il sait
qu'il peut s'appuyer sur l'ensemble de
la communauté nationale
on est là sur un système
fondamentalement enracinée dans la
solidarité nationale sur la question des
avocats il y à deux problématiques la
première ce que j'entends c'est on passe
de 14 à 28
effectivement facialement mais ce qu'il
reste à portée pour les avocats n'est
pas le doublement puisqu'ils à 30% de
csg
il ya 2 % déjà qui ont été décidées par
la profession est donc entre 2029 et
2040 il faudra trouver 5 6% avant 2029
il n'y a pas d'augmentation pour les
avocats et donc on sait et c'est là mon
propose que les avocats sont souvent des
aimants avec moi sur les réseaux sociaux
je n'ai contraire je soutiens les
avocats et voilà le conseil que je leur
donne d'abord on est dans une profession
qui est en grande précarité
on le sait 30% des avocats des jeunes
avocats ne font même pas 10 ans dans la
profession
ils quittent la profession il ne quitte
pas à cause des retraites ils le
quittent parce que le métier est
difficile parce qu'à une grande
précarité des petits cabinets et des
petits avocat et donc il ya la question
des retraites mais au-delà de ça il ya
la question de la traque
évitez de ce métier et la question
justement de renforcer les petits
cabinets et ceux qui sont fragiles et
mon conseil aux avocats aux syndicats et
à la ministre c'est de se rencontrer
pour au delà de la question des
retraites
quand on voit qu'elle va se dérouler
dans 10 ou 15 ans sur les grands enjeux
financiers - glace 2 fait un plan fort
sur une nouvelle attractivité de sommeil
monsieur le président bertin à paroles
oui je peux dans un régime universel
total couvrant tout le monde en
complémentaire en base c'est l'union
soviétique des années 60
enfin sans vouloir choquer nos
excellents amis c'est pas c'est pas le
principe la solidarité il doit y avoir
une part de solidarité on est un pays
très solidaire il ya une part de
solidarité on propose de la cantonner et
puis il ya une part évidemment dans
lequel on prend en compte la
particularité des professions c'est sa
chambre quand même assez normal pourquoi
vous les laissez pas vivre ces régimes
laissez les vivre et une à une en huit
personnes ils sont autonomes
laissez les vivre laisser vivre le
régime des avocats laisser vivre le
régime des indépendants il y en a
beaucoup alors certes qu'il faille ce
qu'il faille les amener à plus de
convergences que les calculs soient
complexes parfois la circularité dont
parlait en commission le le ministre
enfin tous ces sujets qui sont
extrêmement complexes facilitons
simplifiant mais laissons vivre les
régimes en eux mêmes leur façon de les
gérer
moi je voudrais poser une question que
j'ai déjà posé enfin les 2,6 milliards
d'euros qui en plus est en moins
cotisations et entre les cotisations et
puis les les abattement forfaitaire que
vous proposez pour les non salariés
ça coûte 2,6 milliards d'euros au à la
sécurité sociale puisque c'est moins de
siéger et moins de cotisations or
vieillesse et 2,6 milliards seront ils
compenser et comment à la sécurité
sociale je voudrais avoir cette réponse
et je voudrais dire enfin qu'il ya des
perdants et des gagnants dans ces
abattements
il ya des gagnants vous avez raison il
ya aussi des perdants par exemple les
non salariés agricoles qui sont pas
gagnants ils vont payer 400 millions
d'euros 2
de cotisation et ils recevront 300
millions de réductions de base il ya 100
millions de pertes pour les non salariés
agricoles
comment pensez vous réglez sujet
monsieur viguier mais j'ai prise d'un
vivier
non monsieur vélo merci monsieur le
président on a bien entendu le mini
s'agissant des de l'utilisation des
fonds de réserve s'agissant quand même
des avocats le dispositif de solidarité
qui prévoit de lisser le doublement des
cotisations prévoit quand même
d'utiliser les produits des réserves de
la cnbf donc voilà la grande difficulté
c'est que dans votre étude d'impact n'y
a absolument aucune espèce de doctrine
d'emploi des réserves c'est bien la
question est évidemment on ne sait pas
quelle est la doctrine d'emploi des
réserves du fonds de réserve des
retraites ni des réserves constituées
par divers régimes spéciaux on aimerait
avoir quelques projections quel sera le
niveau de ses fonds de réserve à
l'horizon de 2030 c'est qu'elle est quel
est l'emploi envisagé en cas de choc
systémique des réserves constituées par
l'agirc et l'arrco et au sein d'autres
on n'a rien en réalité
problème c'est que on est réduit à
formuler à formuler des hypothèses face
au silence du gouvernement en cette en
cette matière et puis de deux questions
moi j'ai du mal à comprendre comment
autant de gens sont mécontents d'une
réforme est ce que sont que des gens qui
ne comprennent pas que ce que vous
voulez faire les avocats de conseil
national des barreaux a réaffirmé hier
que l'amendement que vous avez proposé
n'était qu'un excédent et qu'il ne
satisfaisait en aucune manière à ces
revendications les experts comptables
aussi se mobilise pour dire à quel point
ils sont perdants dans la dans la
réforme mais vous pouvez pas dire la mer
s'il ya aujourd'hui dans le régime des
experts comptables un taux de rendement
qui est de 8,7 alors évidemment quand
vous le revendez 5,5
ils sont assez doué pour faire des
calculs il me semble et ils le voient
bien que ils vont devoir augmenter leurs
cotisations de l'ordre de
20 à 30% pour des pensions qui vont
baisser de 15%
et puis dernière question c'est on l'a
proposé avec rigueur et d'autres à
plusieurs reprises c'est de ces 2,7
milliards d'euros qui vont manquer du
fait de la baisse de la csg pour les
indépendants va manquer à l'assurance
maladie au premier chef
on sait quelle est la situation de
l'hôpital qui va à qui va compenser qui
va compenser cette perte de recettes
madame matin merci monsieur le président
juste en introduction je voudrais
inviter mes collègues à se reporter à la
page 24 delà de l'avis du conseil d'état
le point 53 qui confirme que arrêter la
circularité de la base de la csg pour
les indépendants sera parfaitement
constitutionnel et que l'abattement qui
existent déjà madame autun page 24
points 53 je vous invite à lire ensuite
ans mais écoutez si vous savez mieux que
le contacte alors ensuite je voudrais
juste parlé un petit peu parce que enfin
des 2,3 même plus pardon des 3 millions
en fait de d'indépendants de chef
d'entreprise
parce qu'il n'ya pas que 70 milles
avocats en france il ya trois millions
de personnes qui sont aujourd'hui des
chefs d'entreprise et des indépendants
dans ce pays et je peux vous assurer
qu'ils ne sont pas tous comme les
avocats et que beaucoup ceux qui sont
représentés notamment par la ceppm élue
de l'ue de paix pardon sont ravis mais
vraiment ravi de pouvoir enfin accéder à
un système universel de retraite
alors je sais bien que quand on a quand
on a proposé de mettre le rsi dans
lequel il souffrait dans l'urssaf et de
créer le sl si vous nous avez promis du
sang et des larmes
et bien je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
on a des sourires et des merci parce que
ça fonctionne et ce sera le cas quand
ils rentreront dans ce système universel
de retraite
parce que voyez-vous bien sûr il ya de
multiples situations mais pour beaucoup
aujourd'hui lâche déquilibre qu'ils
connaissent déjà
il est déjà aujourd'hui à 65 ans
beaucoup ne peuvent pas partir à 67
certains sont même obligés deux ans leur
profession et je pense notamment aux
médecins de continuer à travailler bien
au delà jusqu'à 70 ans
aujourd'hui ce que nous leur proposons
c'est un régime plus solidaire un régime
dans lequel certes il cotiseront
peut-être un peu plus beaucoup beaucoup
moins surtout beaucoup cotiseront - et
surtout leur pension seront garantis
avec des conditions qui seront celles de
tous les autres
merci la parole est à m wulfran qui va
percer un peu différent ce que nous
comprenons tout de même de la réaction
d'un certain nombre de sales à 2
d'indépendance du salarié de salariés et
de professionnels indépendants
c'est que aujourd'hui le modèle encore
en vigueur dans notre pays qui est celui
d'une économie mixte ou oui bah ouais le
modèle français c'est celui d'une
économie mixte est ce qui justifie
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses que les
députés communistes sont
particulièrement attachés également au
sort réservé aux indépendants et aux
professions libérales est ce qui
justifie aussi que nous défendions avec
acharnement que les secteurs
stratégiques de notre pays qui relève
d'un certain nombre de régimes spéciaux
que vous déposez et bien soit maintenu
et soit consolidée à à l'opposé de ce
que vous faites depuis que vous êtes au
pouvoir
et bien ce secteur de l'économie fondée
sur et bien les travailleurs
indépendants les professions libérales
il est fragilisé aujourd'hui il vous le
dise il vous ne le disent que ce soit
ces professionnels de santé que ce soit
ces professionnels de la justice que ce
soit ces professionnels de proximité en
matière de distribution de commerces et
de services privés
et là où nous attirons votre attention
c'est que cela c'est la vie réelle au
quotidien ce que nos collègues et bien
de l'opposition de droite souligne
également en même temps que nous car au
bout du compte c'est la population qui
ont parait du direct juridictionnelle on
parle professionnels de santé mais tout
cela a des incidences au quotidien sur
la vie de nos concitoyens qui sont
inquiets avec ces professionnels d un
site d incidence de votre système de de
retraite tels que il est engagé
un dernier mot monsieur le président
adam dunn ont menacé dit pas s'ils
n'assistent pas on vous écoutera un peu
plus tard on s'amuse à une surprise
toujours avec le même intérêt
donc là on va voter pour le moment
chacun regagne sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
80 et 90 votants et 89 pages aux rites
et 45 tours 27 contre 62 dont les
amendements de suppression de l'article
n'ont pas été adoptés nous en venons au
13 1493 qui le défend malabo gonnot
oui monsieur le président effectivement
nous demandons la suppression de 7 ce
premier alinéa et je voulais revenir sur
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
tout à l'heure une forme d'étonnement en
fait du ministre qui ne comprenait pas
pourquoi tant de gens
en tout cas dans l'assemblée était
contre cette réforme et je voulais
revenir sur le fait qu' effectivement on
a aujourd'hui une unité de l'ensemble
des professions libérales qui sont
représentées notamment dans le collectif
sos retraite qui refusent cette réforme
je voulais parler l'exemple qui a été
donné d'un jeune kinésithérapeute
grévistes qui a compté que sur une année
la réforme reviendrait à 2500 euros en
mois soit l'équivalent d'un mois de
salaire avec une perte sèche de 5% pour
ce type de profession et malgré les
protestations de la majorité on
apprenait début trouviez que les caisses
de professions libérales et celle des
avocats allaient se réunir pour faire
réaliser leur propre étude d'impact dont
les résultats seraient publiés en mars
2020 un communiqué a été diffusé de
professionnels libéraux médecins
vétérinaires chirurgiens dentistes et
sages femmes pharmaciens expert
comptable et commissaire aux comptes
ainsi que notaires et avocats qui a
indiqué poursuivre leur analyse au
projet de loi portant sur la réforme des
retraites en indiquant je cite que les
données présentées dans l'étude d'impact
comme dans les éléments antérieurs m'ont
soumis aux syndicats professionnels
présentent des différences
significatives avec leurs propres
estimations et les caisses ont donc
décidé de demander des expertises des
actuaires indépendant afin de vérifier
de façon objective pour leurs
ressortissants que les hypothèses
présentées
les instances gouvernementales les
modalités précises de calcul des cas
types au regard notamment des régimes
auxquels actuels auxquels cotisent les
professionnels libéraux sont exacts il
s'agit pour ces professions d'établir un
état précis de l'évolution des
cotisations comme une évaluation des
prestations futures et de leur rendement
dans les régimes actuels eux et dans le
futur régime étant également inquiètes
sur le devenir des réserves que les
professions ont constitué donc on voit
là que malgré vos protestations il y a
absolument pas de confiance vis-à-vis de
ce que vous proposez dans votre projet
je pense que vous devriez peut-être vous
poser la question de la raison pour
laquelle des gens aussi différents que
des syndicalistes des salariés ratp des
professions libérales les agriculteurs
et des crises aussi peu confiance dans
vos protestations et c'est peut-être
parce que tout le monde a entendu que de
toute façon il faudrait travailler plus
plus longtemps des mots du premier
ministre est que les études d'impact que
vous avez à présenter malgré les
trucages et après examen attentif des
uns et des autres montre que les
penseurs ont baissé et je pense que vous
payez ainsi le manque de confiance que
avis de la commission générale et
amendements de suppression d'un élément
défavorable mais ma vie mais je me dise
monsieur le président madame boutin
répond je me suis vraiment déjà pour
répondre à madame autant personne n'a
dit que ce n'était pas constitutionnelle
de baisser la csg non ce que nous sommes
en train de vous dire ce nom ce que nous
sommes en train de vous dire c'est que
dans la loi actuelle il n'est pas
possible de dire qu' il y aura une
compensation qui sera inscrite dans la
loi
voilà d'ailleurs on le sait sur les
fonctionnaires le problème c'est que
vous nous dites les enseignants vont
être augmentées et que ça par contre ça
a été retoqué par le conseil d'état a
alerté en tout cas par le conseil d'état
puisqu'on ne peut pas donner une
injonction au parlement a voté une loi à
l'avenir donc c'est ça le sujet
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
cette baisse de la csg elle sera votée
ou pas dans le plfss et elle peut être
mise en cause chaque année et par
ailleurs elle a un impact sur le budget
de la sécurité sociale
donc nous disons haut et fort que cette
mesure est une mesure donc de
compensation et si on veut compenser
c'est bien qu'il ya un manque à gagner
c'est bien qu'ils ne vont pas gagner
dans cette réforme et qu'il faut trouver
un moyen d'amortir le choc
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on vous
reproche quant aux caisses vous nous
dites monsieur le ministre il n'ya pas
d'expropriation de la caisse mais vous
jouez un petit peu sur les mots
pouvez-vous nous garantir que la caisse
des avocats ne sera pas utilisée demain
pour payer notamment la transition
alors oui vous avez vous l'avez même dit
donc c'est pas une expropriation au sens
juridique du terme mais c'est une façon
de vider les caisses des avocats dont
vous jouez sur les mots et l'une et
l'autre pour nous raconter des sornettes
sur un régime dont personne ne veut
parce que il dit seront perdants et
enfin j'insiste sur un point c est ce qu
on peut voter pour une loi au nom de
l'égalité et cetera avec des beaux
principes en prologue dans l'article 1
et ensuite voir que très concrètement il
y aura une détérioration du niveau des
pensions pour les personnes qui sont
concernées
ça c'est pas le progrès c'est la
régression non à la parole on parle on a
beaucoup parlé des avocats et là
j'entends beaucoup parler des
indépendants moi je j'aimerais que sur
les indépendants on fasse un petit peu
pour ceux qui n'ont jamais été qui ne
savent pas du tout ce que c'est d'être
indépendant un peu preuve de modestie il
s'avère que moi toute ma vie
professionnelle
enfin grande partie de ma vie
professionnelle avant d'être député
j'étais travailleurs indépendants et je
sais ce que c'est d'être travailleur
indépendant je sais ce que c'est
effectivement de se retrouver à certains
trimestres a pas pouvoir payer ses
charges c'est un vrai sujet et c'est un
vrai sujet et c'est pourquoi parfois il
peut y avoir des craintes sur une
éventuelle augmentation lycée des
décharges
enfin madame autun
et et mes amis du groupe gdr vous qui
aimez défendre la précarité et vous qui
est d aimé défendre les gens en
difficulté est bien posée vous quelques
questions sur l'autre sur les
travailleurs indépendants parce
qu'aujourd'hui les travailleurs
indépendants sont des gens qui la
plupart du temps au moment où ils
arrivent à la retraite 21% d'entre eux
sont obligés de cumuler un emploi
continuer leurs activités à 67 ans donc
ça si c'est pas de la précarité excusez
moi de vous le dire on a un vrai sujet
et le le système universel de retraite
que nous proposons va englober enfin les
indépendants et les artisans les
commerçants hier un commerçant
effectivement y cotiser peu pourquoi et
cotisé peu parce que quand il arrivait à
la fin de son activité il vendait son
fonds de commerce
mais dans nombre de nos villages dans
nombreux de nos villes les fonds de
commerce ne valent plus rien aujourd'hui
donc ils se retrouvent dans la précarité
ils se retrouvent sans un sou ils sont
obligés de continuer à travailler et moi
et vous qui cité sans arrêt les noms de
des gens que vous avez croisé je
pourrais vous citer des commerçants de
chez moi de mon territoire des artisans
qui sont obligés de contrer continuer à
travailler parfois jusqu'à 70 ans
alors au front le enfin un système digne
permettant de les supporter de se
protéger jusqu'à la fin de leur vie
je mets donc aux voix l'amendement 13
1493 des feux vrac mais le gouvernement
qui est pour qu'entre rejeté le 13 1510
ceux qui le défend monsieur cochrane à
la parole
bon je reviendrai plus tard sur l'idée
que c'est très fort m'avantage des
indépendances pas vraiment d'accord avec
madame vous avez là moi je voulais
revenir sur l'histoire de la csg avec la
trempe pour 30 % l'abattement 30%
d'abattement en gros ces idées que ça va
compenser pour certains l'augmentation
des cotisations alors déjà le premier
problème c'est que ils cotisent sur des
revenus nets et vous allez élargir une
assiette sur la base du super brut
ce super brut d'après christophe perret
pettiti premier vice président de la cdf
à propos des cotisations il explique
qu'en réalité ces cotisations augmentent
de toute façon pour tous y compris après
l'abattement 30% sur la nouvelle
assiette global des cotisations prévues
par le projet de loi appelée super brut
et il a il a une explication assez
détaillé cette question je pourrais
revenir tout à l'heure etc
moi ce que je voudrais savoir c'est
comment vous allez calculé le super brut
en moyenne de combien de pourcentage de
super brut
sera-t-il supérieur honnête avec moi
expliquer un peu l'arithmétique que vous
allez choisir pour essayer de nous
convaincre que en l'augmentant le super
brut donc avec l'abattement de cotillas
son vous prévoyez vous allez comme ça
compenser les augmentations de
cotisations parce que pour l'instant
au delà du fait que ces victimes en pas
dans la loi que ça se définira mais
c'est vraiment pas clair et c'est clair
pour aucune profession libérale merci
merci en réponse la commission bhutto et
pardonnez moi il y avait un amendement
identique le 24 1934 monsieur vais là où
il est défendu
vous avez la parole donnez moi
je réitère la question qui était posée
puisque c'est quand même mentionné un
tableau 24 pages 147 de l'étude d'impact
les 2,6 milliards d'euros qui vont
manquer la sécurité sociale et je pense
en particulier à la branche maladie du
fait de la modification de l'assiette de
csg et crds des indépendants j'aimerais
savoir quels sont les institutions qui
vont être imputé et de quelle manière
elles vont être compensés
ça me paraît important et puis je leur
pose la question pourquoi faisait pas
intérêt à intégrer dans l'étude d'impact
une comparaison de l'effort social au
fiscal des indépendants et des salariés
aux dépenses non contributive de
protection sociale j'ai appelé
évidemment que le taux d'effort n'était
pas le même pour les uns et pour les
autres en particulier entre 1 et 3
passes pour les indépendants merci
monsieur l'avocat général
chers collègues
alors quand même pour le bon
fonctionnement de nos travaux ce serait
bien que les amendements présentés
soient défendus d'être qu'ils sont et
pas utilisé pour aborder d'autres
d'autres sujets donc ce sera un avis
défavorable à l'intervention du collègue
que craig n'a rien à voir avec
l'amendement notamment présenté aucun
sens dit 'tiens donc défavorable
or monsieur président un réponse mafieux
de graines jeu quand même assez étonné
de la réponse parce que pour le coup je
pose une question précise fectivement je
me sers d'amendements mais une question
précise
par rapport à un argument que vous
donnez sur l'augmentation sur la baisse
de la csg
à partir du moment où l'assiette
augmente je vous demande de montrer que
l'assiette ne va pas augmenté
contrairement à ce qui est notamment
affirmé je vous ai cités j'ai voulu
citer un peu plus en détail écrit stop
et il explique les seuls les seuls qui
n'auront pas d'augmentation sont ceux
qui sont largement au-dessus de 3 passes
il parle de l'assiette 120000 euros car
elle ne cotiseront plus au régime
universel ni à la cnbf mais ils n'auront
pas de droit au régime universel ou à la
cnbf et cotiseront toutefois 2 81% au 1
rue pour la solidarité pour bénéficier
de l'équivalent prestation de celles
servies aujourd'hui par la cnbf ils
devront cotiser en madelin ou en
produits assurance vie avec un roman
largement inférieurs et pas
nécessairement avec une défiscalisation
pour les autres la seule question reste
qu elle l'augmentation des cotisations
elle est certaine le gouvernant parle de
5,4 points de plus
après avoir reconnu 6% je trouve que
pour le débat que nous avons là vous
auriez pu utiliser la question puisque
vous nous dit qu'on pose pas de question
à vous poser une question précise sur
cette augmentation de 2 de l'assiette
qui du coup pourrait annuler en grande
partie la baisse de la csg dont vous
expliquer qu'elle va compenser la hausse
des cotisations et vous décidez pas me
répondre je trouve que c'est c'est
peut-être parce qu'en réalité vous
n'avez pas d'autre réponse que celle des
inquiétudes que je viens de citer
merci dont jamais se voir cet amendement
d'effroi prévisions vers manqué pour
qu'entre rejetée nous avons une
discussion commune qui commence par le
23 1840 monsieur
l'eau défendu et
le 118 118 madame antoine oui monsieur
président cet amendement concerne plus
particulièrement la situation des
avocats on l'a dit on vous le redit ya
un régime démographique y est favorable
puisqu'on à près de quatre actifs pour
un retraité
et ça c'est vraiment le signe de la
vitalité c'est la vitalité et
l'attractivité de cette profession mais
pour autant comment voulez vous attirer
des jeunes vers une profession si
derrière les conditions économiques sont
sont compliquées et moi je vais au delà
de cela j'ai une question toute
particulière monsieur ministre qu'on
vous a déjà posé par rapport à la
protection sociale des avocats et on le
sait bien la caisse nationale des
barreaux français la cnbf elle
intervient aussi lorsqu'il y a un
problème d'invalidité d'incapacité on a
des indemnités journalières qui peuvent
être versées par cette caisse aux
avocats alors moi je vous pose et je
vous repose cette question comment
entendez vous faire avec cette
protection sociale des avocats merci
nous poursuivons les amendements
identiques madame ménard le 39 21
merci monsieur le président
effectivement il s'agit d'un amendement
pour supprimer les alinéas 3 et 4 de cet
article 4 ces deux alinéas ronde
applicable système universel de retraite
aux avocats en ballon en balayant au
passage les spécificités de leur régime
de retraite
c'est tout à fait regrettable quand on
sait qu'en faisant passer de 14 à 28 %
les cotisations de retraite de nombreux
cabinets d'avocats pourrait voir dans
l'activité remise en question à cause de
cette augmentation de charge sans
précédent
comme j'ai eu plusieurs fois d'ailleurs
l'occasion de le détailler hier soir
vous allez mettre en péril de nombreux
cabinets d'avocats à commencer par les
plus petits d'entre eux évidemment et
c'est tout notre système de juste
ce qui va être mis en danger puisque
c'est le maillage territorial de ces
cabinets qui va être attaqué par votre
mesure
déjà depuis le début de leur mouvement
de grève ces cabinets souffre et à cause
de votre mauvaise réforme c'est le
fonctionnement même de notre justice qui
est aujourd'hui menacée je vous remercie
monsieur le président merci alors donc
maintenant le 11 1886 monsieur cherpion
défendu le 11 1887 défendu également le
24 1935 monsieur vélo monsieur lambert
juillot défendu madame valentin pour le
25 1386 défendu monsieur gosselin pour
le 27 1395 vous avez la parole
un tout petit mot complémentaires
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites
effectivement je voudrais rebondir sur
la question de notre collègue emmanuelle
antoine en à la question des retraites
on est au coeur du réacteur
mais il y à beaucoup d'autres questions
sur le statut social on peut dire au
sens large des avocats qui ce qui se
pose et je crois qu'il faut vraiment
prendre en compte la particularité de
cette profession il a été dit hier après
midi qu'il n'y avait pas de raison de
mettre en avant plus telle ou telle
profession qu'une autre ah je suis
désolé il ya des singularités
c'est vrai pour beaucoup de professions
indépendantes ont la cité à plusieurs
reprises les médecins les orthophonistes
les commerçants des artisans et il y a
les marins et tant d'autres il ya
évidemment les notaires chers collègues
il y a beaucoup de singularité mais je
crois que toutes les professions non pas
exactement la même place dans la société
c'est pas faire offense aux uns et aux
autres avec les avocats avec les avocats
on a des auxiliaires de justice ils sont
reconnus comme tels et il participe au
maillage à la proximité de la justice y
on affaiblit les avocats qui sont
parfois le seul point d'entrée de
contact avec le droit dans des
départements ruraux avec aussi les
notaires qui assure ce maillage avec
d'autres professions réglementées et
bien il n'y aura
plus d'accès à la justice voilà l'enjeu
exact qui dépasse largement la question
des retraites est ce que l'on reproche
en fait c'est de ne voir que ce prisme
des retraites de s'arc-bouter alors
qu'en réalité il ya beaucoup d'autres
éléments qu'il faudrait prendre en
compte voilà monsieur le président ce
que l'on voulait rajouter
oui merci donc à vie les noces
oui donnez combien devrait d'abord
écouté rapporteur général est ministre
et donc beaucoup a été dit je ne reviens
pas sur l'ensemble de la profession et
ce sera donc un avis défavorable juste
un point parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'amendements qui aborde le sujet
des avocats salariés et je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui les avocats salariés sont
déjà dans le régime général et qu'en
supprimant les alinéas telle que
proposée dans ces amendements vous
entraînerez y ait une distinction au
sein de la profession
aussi cela confirme encore davantage mon
avis défavorable merci monsieur ministre
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président bon j'ai déjà répondu que ce
soit un certain nombre de questions ce
qu elle je n'en reviens pas que ce soit
la cg ou les réserves juste dire parce
qu'effectivement madame la député
antoine vous avez raison j'ai pas
répondu hier donc je réponds parce que
paraît bon 200 fois la même question ça
ça devient lassant et je pense pour vous
aussi donc sur les dispositifs de
prévoyance invalidité décès bien sûr ils
sont maintenus tel qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui sont toujours à la main
d'ailleurs c'est exactement le libellé
de l'article iv ou son troisième alinéa
les travailleurs indépendants pourront
continuer de disposer d'un régime propre
pour l'invalidité des ce qui ne relève
pas de la retraite voilà donc c'est
clairement explicitées dans l'article 4
madame la députée défavorable nous
supposions merci madame voulait
s'exprimer
oui moi je me rends compte qu'en fait on
est en train de tourner en rond le même
les mêmes argumentaires reviennent de
semaine en semaine et ça devient assez
fatiguant notamment par rapport à ce qui
concerne les avocats je crois que hier
on a bien expliqué encore une fois qu'il
s'agissait pour nous ici
d'un projet social dans lequel tout le
monde était concerné et que nous
souhaitions donc effectivement nous
n'avons pas les mêmes projets mais c'est
le nôtre et vous n'allez pas nous faire
changer d'avis de ce côté là nous le
souhaitons et nous le soutenons
d'autre part sur le terrain match alerte
sur la situation actuelle
on a ce matin une alerte également de la
présidente de la cour d'appel de bourges
qui dit que les les retards s'accumulent
après huit semaines de grève des avocats
et que on a aujourd'hui
eh bien oui mais si on appelle justement
à la responsabilité des avocats parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui des situations les
personnes sont jugés pour crimes et qui
risque d'être mise en liberté
donc on est dans une situation qui est
quand même assez grave et je pense que
vous avez bien compris dans quelle
situation on est et qu'il faut
aujourd'hui avoir un minimum de
responsabilité dans ce que vous défendez
est ce que vous savez très bien être
intenable merci alors madame angot et
puis merci monsieur le président alors
tout d'abord il s'agit bien d'un article
sur les travailleurs et travailleuses
indépendant et indépendante et donc la
question précise posée par notre
collègue coquerel tout à l'heure portait
sur ce sujet je voulais tout de même
rappelé en termes de responsabilité et
d'irresponsabilité chers collègues de la
majorité que nous sommes en train de
discuter d'un texte à trous que vous
combler partiellement les trous avec des
annonces qui sont faits à au fur et à
mesure des négociations et des
discussions que vous avez avec tel ou
tel secteur et nous nous sommes censés
voter à l'aveuglé en attendant que vous
ayez fini le travail que vous n'avez pas
été capable de faire en plus de deux ans
et demi alors excusez nous mais en
termes de responsabilité vous vous posez
quand même la sueur sur le sujet et
quand on vous pose
monsieur le rapporteur je comprends
votre embarras vous n'avez pas pensé à
la question sur l'abattement de 30% sur
la csg mais c'est bien une question
précise que se posent les avocats et les
avocates vous êtes incapable d'y
répondre
et après vous vous jouez les surpris et
les surprises que personne n'ai
confiance dans ce que vous dites quand
même
je rappelle ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure le fait que
les caisses de d'indépendants et
d'indépendante vont faire leur propre
expertise
parce que l'étude d'impact de 1000 pages
bourrées de trucs de d'erreurs et de
simulation truqués ne correspond pas et
ne permet pas assez à ces secteurs de
savoir exactement à quelle sauce ils
vont être être mangés et donc c'est
votre irresponsabilité chers collègues
qui fait qu'on se retrouve dans ce flou
c'est vous qui faites le flou c'est vous
qui créez un blocage parce que vous
voulez chambouler un ensemble de
secteurs qui fonctionne en eux leur
premier temps que de travailler plus
pour avoir de moins bonnes pensions
parce que c'est ce que vous avez dit et
ce que dit monsieur le premier ministre
sur l'ensemble de cette réforme
faussement universel et après vous vous
étonnez que personne n'ai confiance dans
ce que vous dites vous récoltez ce que
vous avez semé et nous continuerons donc
à vous donner des précisions à vous
demander des précisions parce que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas simplement nous
qui les demandons mais c'est l'ensemble
des salariés qui sont mobilisés
et quand ils sont en grève ils ont
raison d'être en grève parce que c'est
votre responsabilité
merci monsieur le président je réagis à
l'intervention de la députée de la
république en marche qui en appelle à la
responsabilité des avocats qui ne
devrait plus faire grève parce que et
modem a oui c'est vrai c'est la majorité
en marche et modem qui sont là sur
vauban pour défendre cette réforme des
retraites par points et qui fait
beaucoup de mal à de nombreuses
professions des ouvriers aux avocats et
vous demandez donc à toutes ces
professions d'arrêter de faire grève y
compris les avocats en appelant à leurs
responsabilités mais comment on se fait
entendre dans ce pays
comment on exprime ses revendications
comment on dit qu'un réforme des
retraites est particulièrement injuste
que l'eau soit ouvrier aide soignante
égoutiers bûcheron avocat ou cadres il
faudrait que l'on se taise et que l'on
accepte une réforme particulièrement
injuste les avocats sont peut-être une
profession qui a beaucoup voté pour
votre majorité
ces blouses noires se sentent blues et
aujourd'hui ils se sentent trompés
trahis
parce que ce que vous mettez en oeuvre
jamais ça n'a été écrit noir sur blanc
qu'il faudrait travailler plus longtemps
et que les règles seraient cassés bien
au contraire
le candidat macron à l'élection
présidentielle a dit houle inverse il
n'y aurait pas de mesures d'âge et les
règles ne seraient pas cassés
vous faites tout l' inverse ils se
sentent trahis ils le manifestent mais
avec vous la démocratie c'est une fois
tous les cinq ans entre deux élections
on se tait et on doit accepter et bien
accepter qu'il y ait de la contradiction
qu'il y ait de l'opposition et qu'il y
ait des grèves et il faudra tenir
jusqu'au bout et au delà même si vous
imposez le 49-3 nous continuerons à
manifester notre opposition
monsieur vigala parole oui merci
monsieur le président souffrait mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité que nous
n'ayons pas le même avis le métier qui a
été remis sur les ouvrages où on est
passé on est reparti d'un point de
départ on nous a dit qu'il y avait eu
beaucoup de concertation mais la
concertation ça veut pas dire la
réunionite où on reçoit les gens et on
n'entend pas ce qu'ils ont à vous dire
ont le sentiment que nous avons c'est
que vous avez décidé de faire un régime
soit disant universel sans prendre en
considération les disparités des
situations comment vous pouvez mettre
dans le même régime des salariés et des
indépendants
la votre volonté de mettre les
indépendants dans ce régime donc
soi-disant universel parce que on l'a vu
précédemment un certain nombre de
catégories ont quand même réussi à y
échapper parce qu' il pouvait bloquer
plus que d'autres le pays
mais vous voulez mettre donc les
indépendants dans dans ce régime
avec comme conséquence qu'ils vont
devoir payer à la fois les cotisations
des salariés à la fois les cotisations
des employeurs ce qui va doubler à peu
près la valeur de l'or de l'or de 2,2
hors cotisations ce qui devient
insupportable dans le cadre de leur
fonctionnement quotidien et dans de leur
équilibre économique
et puis je sens aussi chez vous beaucoup
d'exaspération parce que nous débattons
et c'est aussi le rôle du parlement de
parlementer mais si vous ressentez un
certain nombre de blocages dans le cadre
de la discussion de ce texte
d'obstruction comme vous dites c'est
aussi parce que le gouvernement a été
incapable de respecter les délais pour
déposer le texte est passé en temps
programmé si le gouvernement vous n'avez
pas fait peur preuve de cet amateurisme
et bien
il l'aurait déposé le texte en temps et
en heure dans le cadre d'un temps
programmé et nous n'aurions pas eu cette
situation de blocage que vous dénoncez
sans cesse merci monsieur vélo d'abord
dire en dépit des inquiétudes des
magistrats la solidarité des magistrats
à l'endroit de leurs collègues avocats
d'ailleurs ils ont un mouvement de
protestation qui leur sera commun dans
quelques jours pour dire ce qu'il pense
conjointement de la situation et je
crois que faire le procès des avocats en
irresponsabilité parce qu'ils défendent
en réalité à travers le maintien de leur
régime particulier et de leur situation
l'égalité d'accès aux droits en
particulier dans nos territoires ruraux
où beaucoup d avocat travaille seul et
seront menacés de faillite par les
dispositions que vous prenez me paraît
être un acte de responsabilité et
certainement pas le support des
reproches que vous pouvez le faire et
puis je le répète le conseil des
barreaux a bien dit que l'amendement que
vous avez déposé hier ne lui avait pas
été soumis ne répondait pas à ses
préoccupations et n'était qu'un
expédient et d'ailleurs comment pour
être est ce que cela pourrait être autre
chose quand on considère votre
amendement qui évidemment ne fait
l'objet d'aucune espèce d'étude d'impact
on est incapable d'avoir par exemple une
idée du nombre d'avocats potentiellement
concernés par ce seuil de 80 mille euros
on n'en sait rien les choses arrivent
comme ça il pleut sur ce sur ce texte à
trous des morceaux de concertation dont
ceux qui sont censés être l'écho
négociatieurs disent qu'ils ne qui ne
s'y reconnaissent pas et franchement
tout cela n'est pas sérieux et la
réaffectation du produit des plaidories
n'est pas à la hauteur des augmentations
de cotisations que vous allez à imposer
aux avocats de vous allez en effet les
mettre dans une situation économique
extrêmement préoccupante extrêmement
fragile
beaucoup d'avocats qui travaille seul ou
des petits cabinets se casseront la
figure et
nous aurons un problème majeur d'accès
au droit pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
merci madame grand jury la parole si
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues on est au 11e jour de débat on
en l article 4 j'étais présente
quasiment tous les jours et j'ai
l'impression d'entendre à nouveau ce que
j'ai entendu hier l'article 4 c'est
l'intégration de l'ensemble des
indépendants dans le système universel
on a hier beaucoup beaucoup parlé des
avocats la démocratie c'est débattre
la démocratie c'est changer la
démocratie c'est écouter mais c'est
aussi avancer avancer pour l'intérêt des
français et quand je vous entends poser
des questions sur l'assiette des
cotisations la csg c'est l'article 21
j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse avancer je
vous remercie
merci alors nous allons maintenant voter
sur les votes à main levée d'un nouveau
ton tout d'abord sur le 23 8 140
défavorable commissionnement qui est
pour quand
rejetée nous vantons maintenant sur le
sens 18 et suivants
mais ma vie qui est pour contre rejeté
nous en venons au 13 1527 madame autun
vous avez la parole
nous sommes tout à fait dans le sujet en
vous parlant encore une fois des avocats
et le problème c'est que vous nous
renvoyez l'article 21 d'abord ne savons
pas si nous arriverons à l'article 21
j'ai entendu comme vous peut-être j'ai
entendu comme vous peut-être monsieur
legendre ce matin sur france inter nous
expliquer que en gros il avait quasiment
hâte que le 49 3 arrive donc on n'est
absolument pas sécurisé dans le débat
primo deuxièmement si vous répondiez aux
questions qu'on vous pose peut-être
qu'on ne serait pas amenée à les reposer
25 fois voilà et par ailleurs il se
trouve que nous n'avons pas pu déposer
l'ensemble des amendements qu'on aurait
voulu déposer pour une raison simple
c'est que par exemple les annonces qui
sont faites
elles sont faites après le dépôt des
amendements et là en l'occurrence on y
va sur le sujet et qui est le nôtre et
je pose la question solennellement au
ministre vous nous parlez d'un super
brut 1
pour le calcul est ce qu'on peut savoir
quelle va être la différence pour ses
cotisations entre le super brut et le
net quel pourcentage de différence moi
j'ai lu ce que disait le président du
conseil national du barreau de france
si on prend d'un côté la baisse de la
csg et de l'autre côté la hausse des
cotisations pour la retraite
on pourrait au final imaginez que la
hausse est au total des cotisations de
l'ordre de 5 à 6%
est ce que monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez nous dire ce qu'est ce super brut
nous dire s'il y a bien au total une
hausse du montant des cotisations pour
les avocats et pour les indépendants
plus globalement et enfin quelles sont
les garanties pour l'avenir puisque la
hausse de la csg elle n'est pas inscrite
dans le marbre
mais rediscuter année après année dans
le cadre du plfss donc c'est un
engagement qui quelque part langage que
ceux qui vont l'écouter mais
certainement pas inscrit dans le marbre
de la loi et je réitère ma question
puisque je n'ai pas eu de réponse sur la
caisse des avocats et ça vaut pour la
caisse des médecins monsieur le ministre
vous nous dites que vous n'allez pas
exproprier
pouvez vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre ici que la caisse que les fonds
qui sont dans cette caisse est accumulée
depuis des années ne vont pas être
utilisé pour la transition vers votre
système
[Musique]
merci machy rapporteur général dont
défavorable même avis monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le président je encore une fois
j'ai déjà répondu x fois sur la cg
monsieur le président donc j'entends que
l'on puisse ne pas être d'accord avec
moi mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
puisse avancer dans l'examen du texte
parce que on a il ya des choses qui sont
extrêmement claire dans le texte j'ai
souhaité dès le début de ce débat
répondre y compris lorsqu on n'était pas
sur l'amendement y compris lorsqu on
n'était pas sur l'article et je
comprends pas ce qu'il ya eu des
demandes qui était connexes qui ont été
exprimées à plusieurs reprises sur
plusieurs bancs et je pense qu'à un
moment donné
voilà il faut arrêter de reposer dix
quinze vingt fois la même question à
laquelle on a déjà répondu qu' dix
quinze vingt fois il faut avancer dans
l'examen du texte
donc les dispositions de cg nous l'avons
nous avons déjà évoqué y compris
d'ailleurs en commission puisque j'ai
porté un amendement permettant de mettre
dans le dur pardon pour l'expression
dans le dur de la loi les dispositions
qui visent à rapprocher les assiettes
des salariés et des professions
libérales ce sujet est donc extrêmement
connue de la représentation nationale
je pense qu'il est temps qu'on passe à
autre chose monsieur le président
défavorable
défavorable je mets donc vous attend pas
d'événement de prise de parole monsieur
petit maniement monsieur petit
l'appareil
oui très rapidement je pense que c'est
pas pareil tu aller loin et d'aller
contre des ordres c'est à dire on vous
êtes et et en répétant c'est à dire que
non seulement il ya énormément
d'amendements mais en plus on le répète
ces amendements nous font sauter d'un
article à l'autre d'une question à
l'autre les rapporteurs ont été
exemplaires dans leur capacité à essayer
de répondre en détail
malgré le désordre et maintenant vous
nous avez vous venez nous reprocher de
ne pas répondre
on peut pas continuer à répéter répéter
répéter des réponses pour se voir
entendre par départ des vidéos bien
choisis que nous ne répondons pas
maintenant je voudrais revenir sur un
certain nombre de choses qu'on a oublié
de dire mais que j'ai redit ce matin le
système universel
ça veut dire quoi y compris pour les
artisans à partir de de la mise en place
ça veut dire la pénibilité des
infirmières en libéral travail de nuit
voilà ok ça veut dire les 67 ans qui
revient à 64 ans ça veut dire les
carrières en zigzag
on a un exemple la très précis de ce que
le régime universel apporte à des gens
qui aujourd'hui sont broyés par le
système actuel merci madame ni moins la
parole
merci monsieur le président moi je pense
qu'on ne peut pas tolérer que la petite
musique comme quoi un débat de fond
s'installe dans l'hémicycle
soit enfin pour moi c'est pas tolérable
c'est pas tolérable parce qu'en fait
c'est tout simplement faux un débat
c'est un échange
c'est un échange avec différentes
positions avec différents amendements
qui viennent de tous les bords on les
confronte et puis après on les votes
or là on assiste à quoi on assiste
depuis des jours et des jours un
monologue avec à partir d'un amendement
de suppression
tous les sujets sont abordés donc on
répète et on répète et on répète
toujours la même chose sans avancer
parce que dans un hémicycle et quand on
étudie un texte c'est quand même avec
une volonté d'avancer de voter des
amendements et petit à petit de
compléter de construire le texte à
partir de nous les députés orlin c'est
quoi c'est un ralentissement permanent
avec tous les sujets abordés n'importe
quand n'importe comment sans matière
d'avancées donc moi j'entends que quand
on fait ça c'est qu'on s'oppose et vous
avez c'est votre droit mais vous vous
opposez au texte et vous fait mine de
vouloir débattre sur le fond
or vous n'avez qu'une idée en tête c'est
d'obstruer complètement et de toute
façon vous ne voulez pas de la réforme
donc moi j'en suis désolé parce que nous
à la république en marche dans la
majorité en général
ce qu'on voudrait c'est effectivement
avancé sur chacun des articles poser nos
amendements en débattent les voter et
améliorer le texte donc moi vraiment je
suis désolé de 7,1
alors je précise quand même à madame me
manque depuis ce matin on a présenté 193
amendement qui chacun ont été voter
malgré tout un monsieur coquerel à la
parole
oui 20 13
monsieur coquerel
bien j'aurai revenir un petit peu sur la
raisons pour lesquelles alors qu'on
m'explique dans l'article 4 alors même
que la question de la csg à tout alors
été évoqué au début de la discussion par
le ministre posez des questions sur le
super brut ne fait pas partie du débat
là franchement j'ai un peu du mal à
comprendre
alors on a compris chers collègues de
dents marche et du modem que vous aviez
estimé que cette loi devait absolument
passer avant les municipales raisons
pour lesquelles vous vous retrouvez dans
cette situation avec un temps absolument
impossible vis-à-vis de cette loi mais
c'est pas une raison pour caricaturer ce
que vous dit que vous disent les
oppositions donc je reviens sur la
question de la csg la problématique que
nous avons comme beaucoup de choses que
vous avez au fur et à mesure à être
introduit au c'ur à partir de réponses
que vous n'aviez pas les annonces ce
super brut ont commencé alors que
l'examen de la loi avait déjà commencé
d'accord donc en plus de ça il y avait
même pas le temps en termes de dépôts de
temps pour les abonnements de poser les
amendements concret là dessus donc
effectivement on se sert d'autres
endroits pour avoir les réponses
l'article 21 dont vous parlez sans arrêt
renvoie à des ordonnances
il ya rien dans l'article 21 sur la
question de la hausse des cotisations de
manière précise il n'y a rien sur la
manière dont est calculée super brut
donc chers collègues ne dit pas vous ne
vous pressez d un débat dans l'article
21 si on va jusqu'à l'article 21 je vais
pas revenir sur ce qu'a dit ma collègue
au teint tout à l'heure sur les propos
de monsieur logeant de ce matin si on y
arrive ça éclairera pas plus le débat
parce que vous renvoyer aux en or je
trouve monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur que vous pourriez vous dites
nous avait déjà répondu à écouter
ailleurs répété c'est qu'on l'a pas
compris manifestement il ya des
professions qui l'ont pas compris
je vous demande juste comment est
calculé le super brut a qu à combien ça
correspond de pourcentage en plus par
rapport au net
en moyenne c'est des questions simples
si jamais vous l'avais déjà dit vous le
répéter comme ça en tout le monde l'aura
entendu je pense que les gens qui nous
écoutent l'aura entendu mais maintenant
manifestement il y avait beaucoup de
professions qui se demande c'est quand
même pas indécente pour poser ses
questions non mais
miguel madame dalloz merci monsieur le
président moi je voudrais faire deux
remarques une sur la forme et sur le
fond sur la forme moi je constate que
quand vous parlez géant du bien
d'entendre qu'on assiste est un
monologue
je note que chaque fois qu'il ya une
discussion générale d'engager sur des
articles sur des amendements à chaque
fois le groupe modem est le groupe la
république en marche prend la parole
donc c'est pas ce que j'appellerais
premièrement un monologue
deuxièmement ne vous en déplaise
mesdames et messieurs de la majorité ce
n'est pas nous qui avons écrit le texte
c'est votre gouvernement et votre
majorité qui a contribué
si le texte est aussi illisible qu'il
l'est ce n'est pas de notre
responsabilité donc n'allez pas nous
reprocher effectivement l'article 3
comme l'article 1 les articles 2 3 et 4
et 5 rappelle les grands principes de
votre réforme
donc nous sommes bien obligés de revenir
et c'est vrai que vous avez le sentiment
que c'est un on répète les mêmes choses
monsieur le ministre vous avez l'air un
peu ce matin fatigué mais la réalité
c'est que si nous répétons les mêmes
choses
c'est simplement parce que votre
catalogue d'affichage votre catalogue de
bonnes pratiques et de bonnes intentions
voulait répéter sans cesse dans le dans
votre projet de loi et puis sur le fond
maintenant sur le fond quand je vous
entends vous insurgez sur le fait que
nous ferions notre travail mais désolé
l'opposition elle est aussi là pour
faire des propositions demander des
explications des éclaircissements et
marqué sa volonté de refuser ce texte
c'est ça l'opposition
il faut vous l'appreniez vous n'êtes
peut-être pas coutumier du fait qu'il
puisse y avoir une opposition
et enfin dernière remarque et enfin
dernière remarque le la caisse nationale
des barreaux je vais revenir sur un
sujet un peu plus technique mais la
caisse nationale des barreaux de france
l'a dit hier effectivement ils ont été
destinataires de propositions
d'amendements que le gouvernement avait
déposé
mais en aucun cas ils ne l'ont validé et
si justement dans la rue il ya autant de
manifestations c'est parce qu'il ya tant
de profession mécontents c'est parce que
votre texte s'il n'est pas bon monsieur
roussel et nous passerons de vote
merci monsieur le président je constate
effectivement comme ma collègue des
républicains que dès qu'un débat
s'engage
nous sommes systématiquement accusés
d'obstruction et on encore droit des
leçons de démocratie de la part d'une
super majorité sur représentés ici qui
se vante d'avoir la majorité et que à ce
titre nous devrions clore les débats à
chaque fois vous êtes la majorité nous
sommes dans nos conditions donc on
écoute petit roussel
merci monsieur le président en leçon de
démocratie
vous êtes la majorité nous sommes
l'opposition donc ne déposons pas
d'amendement on vote et puis un point
c'est tout m'enfin jamais ça ne se passe
comme ça dans cet hémicycle et
heureusement et quelle que soit la
majorité et quelles que soient les
oppositions
c'est le lieu d'un débat et de
confrontation d'idées mais aussi là où
on pose des questions nous sommes là sur
un article consacré aux avocats
concernant les avocats qui renvoie un
autre article l'article 21 qui lui fait
référence à des ordonnances
d'accord c'est maintenant que l'on parle
des avocats essaient ces jours ci que
vous avez décidé de faire des annonces
concernant la baise les avocats un super
brut une baisse de la csg et les hausses
de cotisations pour les avocats prévu
dans votre texte de loi la question qui
est posée elle est simple comment est
calculée ce super brut
quelle est la différence entre la hausse
de la baisse de la csg et la hausse des
cotes des cotisations combien ça va
coûter
pour un avocat eux mêmes la profession
sont toujours en grève car ils n'ont
toujours pas de réponse donc
faisons pas des grands discours nous
sommes venus ici pour vous poser des
questions précises et tant que nous les
aurons pas nous continuerons de les
poser on va achever les interviews
solignac
merci monsieur le président a écouté
notre collègue l'iman tout à l'heure
j'ai été assez étonné pour ne pas dire
presque irrité par votre conception du
débat à vous vous écoutez j'ai
l'impression que le débat s'est échangé
sur votre texte mais ne pas trop se
poser quand même mais bien sûr que si
bien sûr que si et ne surtout pas
s'opposer à vos desseins funestes parce
que dès lors qu'on le fait nous sommes
taxés de faire de l'obstruction ça fait
plus de deux siècles ici excusez moi
mais l'opposition se poser la majorité
essaye de faire passer ses textes
ça s'appelle la démocratie et que ça
dure le plus longtemps possible et je
crois que vous êtes la première majorité
à ce point à dire combien une opposition
vous embête et vous ennuie c'est cette
incroyable d'en arrivé d'en arriver à de
tels excès qui remettent en cause
fondamentalement la démocratie la
réalité pourquoi vous voulez sortir le
plus vite possible de ce débat sur les
avocats tout simplement parce que vous
êtes pris au piège de la parole
présidentielle
la parole présidentielle c'est quoi
c'est celle qui a dit il faut supprimer
tous ces régimes spéciaux tous ces
régimes autonome en stigmatisant ceux
qui oui sont déficitaires
la parole présidentielle elle a montré
du doigt les régimes de la sncf
les régimes de la ratp mais elle a
oublié que d'autres régimes étaient
presque en tous points conforme à votre
propre philosophie parce que le régime
des avocats c'est un régime qui est
solidaire à l'égard de la nation et donc
vous êtes pris dans vos propres
contradictions
vous auriez dû peut-être tenté
d'éteindre des régimes spéciaux qui
aujourd'hui était fortement déficitaire
mais le président de la république dans
son dans un emballement qui fait aussi
sa caractéristique vous a dit il faut
tous tes supprimé il faut tous les
supprimer même ce qui fonctionne bien
même ce qui reverse de l'argent à l'état
et évidemment ça les principaux
intéressés ne peuvent pas l'accepter et
les français eux mêmes ne le comprennent
pas
merci alors nous allons donc voter sur
le 13 1527 avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et quand madame la présidente
vous souhaitiez
moi je voudrais juste ce président merci
revenir sur des question de sémantique
parce que je crois que ça tourne en rond
effectivement puis quelques temps et la
différence profonde entre débats idées
de fond et travail parlementaire c'est
un peu ça qui se joue aujourd'hui on est
législateur qu'on est les débats de fond
sur les idées de fond je suis d'accord
et c'est ce qu'on fait mais pour autant
le débat dont on parle c'est à dire
celui qui consisterait à amender un
texte au fil de l'eau on ne peut pas le
faire et vous ne pouvez pas nier ça
puisque nous passons notre souci je
pense être le porte parole un peu de
ceux qui s'expriment parfois pas souvent
pour vous dire que non le vrai débat et
le travail parlementaire de fonds ne
peut pas l'effectuer le temps qu on
reste sur les mêmes articles avec des
amendements identiques qui suscite à
chaque fois une discussion générale
et voilà ce sont des discussions
générales à répétition et pas du travail
de parlementaire à répétition donc voilà
ce qui est dénoncé aujourd'hui mais moi
je n'ai pas d'avis là dessus je vous dis
simplement qu'il faut pas jouer sur les
mots tout le temps et personne les
fatiguer ici de le faire c'est la
répétition qui est fatigante pour tout
le monde
alors monsieur rebeyrotte a demandé pour
un rappel au règlement je vous propose
qu après on suspend dans quelques
instants
parce que serait ce que pour respirer un
peu pour président monsieur le président
avez raté will simplement au titre de
l'article sont la question est sur notre
compteur on constate encore plus de
31000 200 amendements
est-ce que vous avez le même chiffre et
je voudrais répondre simplement à nos
collègues en disant que la parole
présidentielle c'est aussi pas de 49,3
comme ici sauf obstruction parce que
l'obstruction ça interdit les travaux et
ça fait en sorte que nous ne puissions
pas sortir dans des délais raisonnables
un texte qui puisse véritablement être à
la hauteur de l'enjeu est donc je
voudrais simplement demandé à nos
oppositions une fois de plus de
réfléchir alors logique d'obstruction
mais sa collègue à la voile avant de
suspendre je précise malgré tout que
depuis 9 heures nous avons passé 210
amendements on est à plus de 100 à
l'heure voilà nous suspendons nos
travaux pour cinq minutes
[Musique]
merci
je fais impériaux
alors la séance est reprise par ap le
règlement oui s'il vous plaît monsieur
le président au nom de l'article 100 sur
le droit d'amendement des députés
puisque systématiquement à chaque fois
mes collègues de la république en marche
fonds d intervention pour le remettre en
cause ici je voudrais donc posé des
questions très précises puisque il vient
d'être dit que la menace du 49-3 qui est
l'armé nucléaire pour tuer un débat
parlementaire
et cette fois-ci brandi en cas
d'obstruction
ça veut dire que s'il y avait
obstruction il y aurait le 49-3 pour
tuer le débat parlementaire alors je
voudrais clairement vous poser la
question pour vous vous l'a calculé à
quel niveau l'obstruction aujourd'hui
nous sommes en train d'avancer dans ce
texte
à raison de 100 amendements adoptés à
l'heure à partir de quel niveau vous
jugez que c'est de l'obstruction il
faudrait que l'on aille à 200 à 300 un
moment de l'heure nous avons déposé dix
mille amendements contre ce texte qu'une
majorité de français ne veulent pas est
ce que c'est de l'obstruction quand nous
sommes en phase avec la majorité de
l'opinion
à partir de quel niveau faudrait-il que
l'on dépose des amendements il faudrait
que l'on en dépose que 200 300 comme
vous qui défendez ce texte
eh bien voyez-vous il faut que vous
acceptiez que dans ce pays il y ait des
gens qui pensent différemment de vous
tout simplement et que nous puissions
l'exprimer ici parce que c'est le lieu
où on fait résonner la voix du peuple de
france et parfois cette voie elle est en
contradiction avec la majorité
merci mais là votre timbre puis monsieur
minière
oui merci monsieur le président sur tout
à fait les mêmes fondements que mon
collègue fabien roussel et dans son
prolongement parce que au fond on a
l'impression que vous tombé de l'armoire
parce que vous découvrez que
l'opposition s'oppose et qu'elle le fait
dans des termes qui sont les thèmes qui
lui sont propres et qu'elles décident ce
n'est pas à vous de décider quel est le
contenu de nos amendements qu'elles sont
le contenu de nos interventions et si
cela vous convient ou ne vous convient
pas quant à l'obstruction quant à
l'obstruction
mes chers collègues de la majorité en
marche j'aimerais bien que nous fassions
un petit décompte des interventions des
députés de la république en marche en
nombre d'heures passées a expliqué que
la façon dont l'opposition s'oppose ne
convient pas parce que je vous assure
qu'en termes d'obstruction c'est assez
énorme et madame la rapporteure au lieu
de passer d une des minutes voire des
heures et des heures
madame la présidente de la commission et
d'autres collègues de la république en
marche vous passez un temps infini à
critiquer la méthode de l'opposition nos
positions 1 alors que c'est vous répondu
à nos questions ça vous prendrai
beaucoup moins de temps et on pourrait
passer au sujet suivant et ben oui je
termine là dessus d'un mot par ailleurs
tout le monde peut constater que nous
sommes sur un débat de fond comme nous
l'avons été au moment de la commission
et si nous avions pas été en tête-- la
question du revenu d'activité moyen par
tête par exemple n'aurait jamais été
posée dans tous les troubles qui sont
les troubles actuels de la majorité
parce que nous sommes en plein flou et
voilà le problème c'est que vous ne
répondez pas parce que vous ne savez pas
répondre merci monsieur 1000 yens
oui merci monsieur le président sur le
fondement de l'article sont bien
évidemment je me répondre à ces
accusations je pense que la majorité et
notamment le président de l'assemblée
nationale avait proposé lors d'une
réunion des présidents de groupe de
réunions de bureau le temps législatif
programmé non pas 50 non pas à 50 non
pas à 100 mais à 120 heures
ce ce temps législatif programmé a été
refusée par deux groupes
madame otages nous ait laissé par les
laissez moi parler s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
bon il a été refusé par deux groupes et
seulement deux groupes gdr et la france
insoumise c'est une des preuves de
l'obstruction c'est une des preuves du
fait que ces gens là ne veulent pas des
maths
ils ne veulent qu'une chose c'est faire
durer les débats le maximum en revenant
systématiquement tout le temps sur les
mêmes sujets qui sont dans le texte à
différents endroits qu'on atteindra
peut-être pas parce qu'ils veulent pas
qu'on y aille donc il ya un moment je
veux bien vos droits
ils sont irréfragable pour reprendre les
termes que vous aimez bien sûr vauban
mais assumé le fait que vous voulez
simplement faire capoter ce projet il
n'y a pas de problème là-dessus mais le
est dit est dit aux français que vous
assumez votre obstruction à preuve
madame autun les fameux 700 milles sous
un moment que vous avez validé m e 15 9
oui merci monsieur le président un
rappel au règlement sur le fondement de
l'article 100 sur le bon déroulement de
nos débats je voudrais redire à
l'ensemble de ne connaît que évidemment
le droit d'amendement est fondamentale
et c'est justement parce que nous
restons respectons le droit d'amendement
que nous sommes assez surpris par ce qui
se passe en ce moment est une petite
musique qui est en train de s'installer
super on fait du sens à mon nom à
l'heure et puis bientôt à faire du 150
amendements à l'heure comme si c'était
la qualité de notre débat qui en
dépendent et et bien nous croyons le
contraire parce que quand on fait sans
amendement de leur ça veut dire qu'on ne
l'ait discutant au contraire qu'il n'y a
pas de discussion sur le fond et que ce
sont des animaux point virgule des
abonnements sur la forme nous préférons
nous voir moins d'amendements mais sur
le fond et qui permette le débat et qui
permettent les changes qui permettent
d'améliorer la loi qui permet deux c'est
ça notre rôle et ça n'est pas de battre
un record celui du super u en train de
faire du 150 mme150 à mon nom et je
voudrais juste pour terminer je pense
que je pense que évidemment le droit
d'amendement est fondamentale et c'est
votre droit et nous le respectons mais
tout irait mieux si on supprimait les
trente mille amendements qui ne sait
veut rien et qui sont les amendements
dilatoire pour se concentrer sur les
2000 ou 3000 amendement qui sont les
amendements qui leur vivier non
rapidement monsieur le président
rappelle règlement sur l'article 100 je
vais juste dire à bruno myle yens qu' il
aime beaucoup mais quand même le temps
législatif programmé le gouvernement
pouvait très bien le mettre en place à
la seule condition qu'ils déposent le
texte six semaines avance sur le bureau
de l'assemblée nationale donc ni les
sons est-ce qu'il peut terminer je parle
pas très souvent on peut éventuellement
s'écouter ça sera pas mal
la deuxième chose lorsque même le plus
lent ferrand avait proposé qui est en
l'état du programme avec notre groupe
hot et même dit qu'on était prêt à voir
si l'ensemble du groupe était d'accord
ça n'a pas été le cas
chers collègues quand il ya 100
amendements alors ne boudez pas votre
plaisir peut pas dire d'un côté qui
passe du blocage avec trente mille
amendements je sais pas plus une action
du point je peux terminer jeudi chers
collègues peut pas d'un côté dire on va
cent à l'heure et le regretté alors que
franchement un moment où on avance ça me
semble nettement mieux donc monsieur le
président on ça serait bien que comme en
a parfaitement bien démarré ce matin moi
j'ai dit avec le groupe depuis le début
vous êtes mis dans la seringue tout seul
fallait pas mettre la date butoir du 3
mars à partir de là il n'y aurait pas eu
de sujet donc maintenant
ne tombez pas dans le cul andré laignel
qui avait déclaré vous le savez tous
vous avez juridiquement tort parce que
vous êtes politiquement minoritaire
ça a été prononcé il ya plus de 40 ans
n'oublions pas que la démocratie a là un
coude alain prix elle exige de se
respecter de s'écouter et d'avancer
monsieur vélo un rappel au règlement
[Musique]
merci monsieur président sur le
fondement de l'alinéa 5 de l'article
sont on a depuis ce matin à bord d un
certain nombre de sujets de fond
on a posé beaucoup de questions
certaines précise certaines soulevant un
certain nombre d'incompréhensions de
manque de divergence d'interprétation
nous essayons d'aller au fond des choses
que ce soit l'occasion de la mort de
l'examen d'un de nos amendements nous
avons déposé que 700 que ce soit
l'occasion à l'occasion de l'examen d'un
amendement d'un autre groupe
je comprends et je conçois que le fait
que ça se passe bien qu'on aille au fond
des choses vous dérange mais la réalité
est celle là c'est que nous travaillons
et que vous n'avez de cesse d'essayer de
revenir à l'idée de cette obstruction au
fond ce que sera la révèle c'est que
vous aimeriez que les mécontentements
les colères les désaccords s'arrête aux
portes de l'assemblée nationale et moi
je pense qu'en réalité c'est une
nécessité qui s'ils s'expriment les
contradictions les colères elle
s'exprime de diverses manières et elle
s'exprime aussi par le choix qui a été
fait par un certain nombre de groupes de
déposer beaucoup d'amendements que vous
qualifiez d'obstruction mais si nous
n'avons pas cette espèce de 2,2 de
violence symbolique dans le débat
parlementaire et bien ça ne sert à rien
de débattre et on ne sait pas parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec vous qu'on
est contre la france voilà et je pense
que nous sommes les uns et les autres
élus élus élus pour dire pour dire ce
que nous entendons et vous ne pouvez pas
considérer systématiquement que vous
avez raison contre l'ensemble du pays et
c'est pourtant ce que vous prétendez
alors mettez vous au travail content que
nous essayons nous mêmes de le faire
merci je vaux crachera tout était dit on
va reprendre gens qui m'en nos débats on
a bien avancé diatta n'y a pas de
problème on va leur prendre
j'aurais juste te dire une chose au nom
de l'article sont pour la bonne tenue du
débat c'est par rapport aux collègues
bruno myle yens c'est que pour débattre
à peu près sereinement encore ne faut-il
pas mentir d'accord sur rien évidemment
non mais tout à l'heure il a expliqué
quelque chose je réponds par rapport à
ça et pour simplement que ceux qui nous
écoutent et la vérité on n'a fait
qu'appliquer le règlement sur la
question du temps programmé
je vous rappelle que vous êtes les seuls
responsables du fait que le temps
programmé n'a pas pu être appliquée
parce que vous n'avez pas respecté les
délais et que si vous n'avez pas
respecté les délais c'est que vous
vouliez à tout prix que c'est toi passe
avant les municipales dont vous êtes les
seuls responsables
il n'y a pas ici des groupes qui dans le
cadre du règlement aurait refusé c'est
vous qui vous étiez en situation la
deuxième chose arrêtez s'il vous plaît
de mentir sur l'histoire des sept cent
mille un moment je ne vois pas je ne
vois pas quel est l'intérêt vous avez
déjà été pointée par des chèques news là
dessus je ne vois pas quel est l'intérêt
d'inventer l'idée que 700 mille
amendements aurait été déposé c'est un
mensonge c'est un mensonge
c'est à mon sol qui vient de chez vous
ça a été montré dans la presse donc je
serais vous maintenant que ça a été
montrée ne répétez pas ce genre de
mensonges parce que ça ne fait
qu'embrouiller les modalités du débat
il n'ya pas 700 milles des amendements
déposés il n'ya pas 700 mille
amendements déposés sous un moment c'est
un mensonge donc vous continuez à
répéter des mensonges et je vous
rappelle qu'il y a deux groupes dans
cette assemblée qui ont fait une
proposition qui est le fait de reporter
le vote
après la conférence de lille en 2d ce
qui aurait permis d'avoir cette semaine
de débats d'arrêter les choses couperet
et vous aurez même permis de
reprogrammer à temps programmé qui vous
aurez réglé vos en venant au 13 1544 qui
fera l'objet d'un vote électronique et
la demande du groupe de la france
insoumise
le scrutin est à lancer dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée nationale et qui le
défend
malabo gounod à la parole merci monsieur
le président alors c'est un amendement
effectivement de suppression de l'alinéa
4 dans cet article 4 qui porte sur les
indépendants je rappelle pour que tout
le monde comprenne bien et nous nous
voulons supprimer cet alinéa 4 qui porte
précisément sur les avocats salariés et
nous revenons à nos questions très
précises
madame la présidente de la commission il
s'agit pas d'une intervention général
des fois nous en avons et nous assumons
de faire des interpellations général là
c'est une question très précise
puisqu'on parle des avocats et on parle
et on vous demande ce que pose
d'ailleurs des représentants le vice
président du cnpf sur cette question
d'abattement de 30% rappelant vous
prévoyez donc un abattement de 30% sur
la csg pour compenser une partie en
partie la hausse des cotisations
actuellement les avocats cotisent sur le
revenu net est donc vous dites que vous
allez augmenter l'assiette des
cotisations les castes is an les calculs
en sur le super brut un super brut qui
n'est pas défini donc nous nous vous
demandons quel est le calcul de ce super
but je crois que c'est une question très
précise et vous n'y avez pas répondu
vous renvoyer à un article 21 nous
sommes nous avons lu l'ensemble du texte
l'article 21 est une ordonnance qui ne
donnera pas plus de réponse précise
donc encore une fois la question est de
savoir de quel montant va être calculée
le super brut s'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose de général et ça sert à
rien de nous dire article 21 puisque
l'article 21 il répondra pas plus cet
article 21 1 rappelons le procède en
disant je vais vous le dire tout tout
tout le présente amendement vise à
préciser l'habilitation à adopter
l'assiette des cotisations et
contributions sociales des travailleurs
indépendants en prévoyant que la future
assiette sera déterminé par application
d'un abattement de 30% aux bénéfices ou
rémunération tenant compte de l'assiette
des cotisations applicables dans le
système universel de retraite
oui on est perdus parce que c'est
complètement flou et donc là excusez moi
chers collègues
c'est un amendement précis qui demande
une réponse précise oui non
alors on ne sait pas assumer que vous ne
savez pas assumer que vous avez mal
préparé cela assumer que vous faites des
annonces au fur et à mesure et assumée
qui n'a absolument aucune confiance
rapporteur général
oui pour ce nouvel amendement de
suppression d'un alinéa
ce sera un avis défavorable pour ce 211e
amendements identiques ou quasiment
identique aux précédents jeux ministre
vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président c'est donc
encore une fois vous poser des questions
dont vous avez les réponses c'est à dire
que quand vous trouvez une nouvelle
question que par hasard vous n'auriez
pas posée depuis douze jours
en fait la réponse vous l'avez puisqu'il
suffit de lire à la page qui correspond
à l'étude a passé la page 146 vous avez
la réponse si vous verrez la définition
du super brut
bon donc voilà on peut pas dire que ce
soit très très très passionnant passé
une heure sur soi puisque vous avez déjà
la réponse
pas un jeu 146 défavorable
madame dernier jeu de l'art
merci monsieur le président moi j'ai une
amie qui est avocate une grande amie
depuis deux jours elle est ravie parce
qu'on ne fait que parler des avocats et
je suis pas sûr que ce coup de lumière
depuis deux jours sur les avocats
finalement leur rendre service parce que
vous êtes en train d'expliquer au reste
de la population que eux ils ne doivent
pas être dans notre système universel de
retraite
je crois que l'article 4 il est sûre les
indépendants donc moi je pense à ma
coiffeuse
je pense à mon boucher je pense à mon
boulanger à l'artisan qui est venu faire
des travaux chez moi au cabinet
d'infirmières qui est installée juste à
côté de chez moi
et caetera et caetera cet article ils
l'attendent parce qu'il s'agit aussi de
leur retraite
donc arrêtons s'il vous plaît de ne
parler que des avocats vraiment arrêté
et puis alors après je suis désolé mais
au risque encore que vous brandissez vos
rappels au règlement
quand on se plaint d'une date butoir
alors que depuis le début du mandat
chaque projet de loi à une date butoir
et que ça ne pose aucun problème
je ne vois pas pourquoi pour ce projet
de loi ça pose un problème si ce n'est
de s'en servir pour afficher justement
que vous ne voulez pas le débat et quand
on se plaît de manquer du temps mais
arrêtez de nous faire perdre du temps
arrêter de poser des amendements le
rapporteur il a dit de 5e sur les mêmes
choses pour supprimer répéter et répéter
merci donc arrêtez monsieur 1000 yens
oui merci monsieur le président alors
comme cette assemblée est friande de cas
concrets
moi je voudrais prendre le cas concret
d'un boucher vous en ai parlé
machar collègues se boucher s'appelle
michel c'est un indépendant on peut
parler des indépendants des artisans oui
non non mais vous avez parlé des avocats
sur les indépendants et sur les artisans
moi je veux en parler là ce boucher
aujourd'hui il est à la retraite
monsieur et il a une carrière compliqué
parce que c'est pas un boucher en
boutique c'est un boucher sur les
marchés il a connu une première partie
de carrière assez florissante à l'époque
où les marchés étaient bienvenues puis
il ya eu une période de déclin
il a dû taper dans ses réserves
personnelles alors évidemment il avait
cotisé à sa caisse mais a minima comme
beaucoup de commerçants l'avait fait et
ils ont tapé dans leur capitalisation
quand les choses allaient mal et
aujourd'hui il est en retraite avec une
petite retraite qui est inférieur au
smic largement inférieurs au smic ce
boucher cet artisan boucher aujourd'hui
à 78 ans il travaille tous les week-ends
pour améliorer sa pension de retraite
donc je voulais leur rendre hommage et
lui quand on m'a parlé de la réforme des
retraites il a dit j'aurais bien aimé
qui est ce système là au moment où moi
j'étais en activité
parce qu'au moins j'aurais pu cotiser
obligatoirement à quelque chose qui
m'aura assurer un minimum de pension que
je n'ai pas aujourd'hui et se boucher je
veux lui rendre particulièrement hommage
parce que figurez vous messieurs que
même si je suis un député playmobil se
boucher qui s'appelle michel c'est mon
oncle
madame gonnot je rappelle que nous
parlions la de l'alinéa 4 de l'article 4
qui porte sur les avocats et que mac est
notre question des coûts dont madame
gonnot
[Applaudissements]
et on s'appuie rappelle d'ordre 1 et
donc nous parlons des avocats parce que
ils sont concernés sur ce sujet mais sur
des alinéas précédents qui parlait des
travailleurs et travailleuses
indépendantes chers collègues si vous
étiez présent et attentif et attentive
ce dont je ne doute pas vous auriez
entendu nous auriez entendu nos
interpellations par exemple soit si par
exemple un peu par exemple sur ce qu'ils
n'hésitent ce jeune par exemple sur ce
jeune kinésithérapeute qui faisait lui
le calcul des baisses que vont
occasionner
vos mesures et qui étaient mobilisés
avec d'autres donc on a beaucoup
d'exemples qu'on peut et qui permettre
d'y lussier cela et ce quand nous
proposons des questions précises et que
nous cherchons des réponses précises
c'est parce que dans les faits je sais
plus quel député de la majorité cité le
conseil d'état dans les fêtes
votre étude d'impact est truffé
d'erreurs ça a été prouvé et retrouvé et
que vous passez votre temps à rajouter
des annonces que les premiers et
premières concernées nous nous faisons
le relais des interrogations qui sont
portées par les premiers et premières
concernées ne comprennent elles et eux
mêmes pas et donc vous récoltez le fait
que ce projet de loi qui est pourtant un
projet d'ampleur qui n'existerait de
prendre le temps de répondre précisément
et de comprendre a été bâclée et donc
merci la parole et à madame dalloz
depuis j'ai bien noté moi tu votes de
rennes après merci monsieur le président
quand j'entends certains députés de la
majorité dire mais nous vous ne parlez
que des avocats non je ma première
intervention ce matin la première qui a
parlé des coiffeurs c'est moi donc j'ai
cité les experts comptables et avocats
les experts comptables les artisans les
commerçants et les coiffeurs donc on n'a
pas de leçon à recevoir
et je me garderais bien d'en donner à
qui que ce soit la condition qu'on se
respecte c'est le premier élément de ma
réponse
deuxièmement
sur gens tendent à l'instant dire parler
de la vraie vie mais écoutez aujourd'hui
si on insiste aussi sur les avocats il
faut vous dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'audiences qui ne peuvent pas
être menées à leur terme qu'il ya
beaucoup de justiciables qu'ils
attendent et le notre système judiciaire
est totalement bloqué donc c'est un vrai
sujet parce qu'il y a des justiciables
en attente de d'une décision d'une
audience qui ne peut pas être tenu donc
je crois qu'il faut sortir rapidement de
ce blocage là pour que l'ensemble de nos
justiciables en france puisse avoir le
service de justice auxquels ils peuvent
prétendre
premier aspect et sur le fond va sur le
le débat moi je voudrais rappeler à
chacun que on peut travailler s'opposer
dialoguer l'assemblée nationale était le
lieu même du débat démocratique à dire
que il ya une majorité et il ya des
personnes qui ne sont pas d'accord sur
certains aspects du texte proposé mais
de grâce patientons respecte en écoutant
que vous soyez excéder les députés de la
majorité cela pu s'entendre
cela fait maintenant 10 jours que nous
sommes sur le texte mais mais la
patience est une vertu
moi je vous invite largement à attendre
que le débat avance au rythme où ils
avancent et que nous ayons des réponses
pour chaque catégorie de françaises et
de français que votre texte inquiète
légitimement et il a t'il sont en droit
d'attendre des réponses que vous
fournissez il est vrai que monsieur
thorel
merci monsieur le président madame ovono
va poser une question précise le
ministre vous a renvoyé à la lecture de
la page sans garantie ce que j'ai moi
même lui avait posé une question vous
profitez de votre amendement pour poser
question sur le super brut jolie page
ainsi la nouvelle assiette de
prélèvements sociaux des indépendants
correspondra aux revenus super brut
c'est-à-dire les revenus professionnels
retenus avant déduction des cotisations
sociales obligatoires et la part des du
type de la csg diminué d'un abattement
forfaitaire
voilà un premier élément de réponse qui
me paraît précis par rapport à une
demande de définition
enfin je prends pas souvent la parole
mais dans votre projet présidentiel
vous avez besoin de deux points de pub
pour faire tous vos projets sociaux dans
votre projet de contre-réforme des
retraites
les deux points pibil sont consacrées
aux retraites donc on se demande ce que
vous passez augmentations de salaires
etc dans votre comportement doit votre
contre-projet de retraite vous mettez
tout le monde au smic mais vous ne
précisez pas quel est le montant du smic
est ce que c'est celui aux actuels et
que celui de 15% augmenter tel que prévu
par le président parle par le candidat
mélenchon est ce que c'est celui qu'on
entend dans les cortèges à 1600 1800
euros
alors pardon pas d'excès pas d'excès
d'autre part et pas de leçons sur les
demandes de précisions parce que par
ailleurs votre contre projet repose sur
rien et vous l'avez fait aux 4 21
monsieur brunel
[Applaudissements]
nous écoutons mathieu brunelle oui
monsieur le président au moment de ses
différentes interventions
moi je ne mets pas en doute mes
collègues qui rencontrent des coiffeurs
des bouchers des boulangers des avocats
des kinés nous pardon ou des experts
comptables je suis persuadé qu'ils
rencontrent mais nous on en rencontre
aussi alors ce que vous rencontrez vous
dites qu'ils sont d'accord avec votre
réforme et nous ce qu'on rencontre ils
disent qu'ils sont pas d'accord donc
excusez moi mais nous on vous avait
proposé pour qu'on soit tous d'accord un
référendum parce que les bouchers les
boulangers les ouvriers et les employés
auraient pu s'exprimer donc on aurait
bien vu qui est d'accord avec vous qui
est pas d'accord avec nous voilà c'était
le meilleur moyen démocratique de deux
de pouvoir continuer à débattre après
mais vous avez pas voulu donc maintenant
accepter quand même que nous sommes en
désaccord profond avec cette réforme
excellent accepté également que nous
fassions des propositions d'amendements
constructif parce qu'on a besoin de
savoir
on ne sait pas tout on nous renvoie la
page 154
mais on sait toujours pas comment ça va
être financé on connaît toujours pas la
valeur du point d'indicé
on sait pas non plus la jeux d'équilibré
alors avoué quand même qu'on a le droit
de se poser des questions et c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire ici avec nos
amendements c'est un lieu où il faut
qu'on débatte est un lieu où on fasse
des propositions c'est le lieu où si
l'opposition et non pas l'obstruction
comme il est dit souvent par mon
collègue à côté c'est une opposition qui
est constructif et qui parle aussi
quitté moines et qui relaie les
réactions que nous avons dans la rue et
aussi être dans les contacts que nous
avons donc voilà on est bien dans nos
baskets on est bien dans nos souliers et
on continuera d'apporter nos amendements
constructif chacun regagne sa place nous
allons donc voter sur l'amendement des
battues c'est à dire le 13 1544 avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votons 105 mais 91
majorité 46 pour 15 contre 76 amendement
n'est pas adopté le 24 1936 et monsieur
solignac à la période merci monsieur le
président je voudrais à mon tour vous
parlez des artisans et je pense que vous
ne me ferez pas le reproche de faire de
l'obstruction voulant parler d'une
profession dont les retraites pour une
carrière complète son sont environ à
1000 euros comme elles le sont pour les
commerçants et c'est même un peu moins
pour les commerçants que pour les
artisans et également pour les
agriculteurs les artisans cotisent
jusqu'à un plafond de sécurité sociale à
hauteur de 25 4% et vouloir les faire
passer à 28,12 comme les salariés c'est
une marche importante à monter
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre vous
vous l'avez reconnu et je vous accorde
cette honnêteté d'avoir dit que vous
aviez conscience que c'était une marche
importante à monter nous avons du mal à
voir comment ces artisans peuvent
trouver place dans votre nouveau système
universel de retraite lui rappelle qu'un
indépendant et son propre employeur
qu'il s'acquitte de la totalité des
cotisations patronales et salariales
avec bien entendu une assiette de
cotisations qui peut varier en fonction
de son activité
j'ai bien compris que la durée de
transition allait s'étaler sur 15 années
j'ai bien compris qu'il y aurait un
lissage
mais je voudrais vous interrogez
monsieur le ministre sur ce lissage
parce que il interviendra par ordonnance
et comprenez que nous ayons toutes et
tous besoin d'être éclairés et pour le
coup vraiment je pose la question non
pas pour essayer de tendre un quelconque
piège non pas pour essayer de faire
obstruction mais parce que je crois que
les députés mais plus encore les
intéressés c'est à dire les artisans ont
besoin de savoir ce que sera ce lissage
alors monsieur le ministre
quid de ce lissage voulait
vous faire appel aux réserves de
certains régimes
ma question était extrêmement précise
oui ou non est ce que vous allez faire
appel aux réserves de certains régimes
lesquels les herbes et puis comment dans
quelles conditions je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le président merci
chers collègues solignac bas pour cette
intervention je sais que vous êtes
particulièrement attachés aux artisans
et aux commerçants
ceci étant dit ce sera tout même un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement parce que
à travers la suppression des alinéas
cinq à huit vous proposer tout
simplement de mettre en dehors du
système universel les commerçants et les
artisans et que defacto ça les priverait
de toutes les solidarités générationnel
que va permettre ce système de toutes
les solidarités en termes de droits que
cela va permettre donc pour beaucoup
cela se traduirait par une précarité
entre toute nue aussi ce sera un avis
défavorable sur la suppression de cet
alinéa de coordination
ben parce que nous avions adopté dans
l'article de jean merci merci monsieur
le ministre
oui monsieur le président je suis député
solignac sur le fait que vous vouliez
supprimer une nouvelle fois des alinéas
5 à 8 mon avis sera que défavorable vous
avez cela étant choisi d'étayer votre
propos avec un sujet qui a été peu
abordée si l'on parle et je pense des
dizaines d'heures du sujet des avocats
vous au moins vous allez concentrer sur
un sujet qui a été peu abordée et qui
pourtant est aussi représentée ici ce
n'est plus de la diversité de notre
population active française les
commerçants les artisans
donc je prendrai quelques instants pour
vous répondre sur ce sujet qui n'a
étonnamment pas fait l'objet de débat
encore après dix jours ici dans cet
hémicycle le changement d'assiette pour
les cotisations vieillesse
vous avez raison de souligner que ça va
évoluer en passant de 23 à 28 12 mai
vous l'avez aussi entendu il y aura un
changement d'assiette de cg et pour eux
non seulement les faits sera
complètement compensé c'est à dire qu'il
y à 0 aux collations c'est totalement
neutre pour l'ensemble des artisans
commerçants
mais surtout c'est qu'ils vont
bénéficier de tous les avantages du
système universel de retraite et
notamment puisque vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le minimum de pension à
85% du smic et pour bien connaître aussi
la vie des artisans les commerçants je
peux vous dire que ça va beaucoup
beaucoup modifié comme ça a été très
bien décrit par un député qui est
intervenue deux heures leur vie à la
retraite
voilà pour les quelques éléments que je
voulais vous apportez monsieur le député
défavorable à la parole le sujet le
sujet abordé complexe il ya plusieurs
formes d'exercice de la profession que
ça sur un commerce à un artisan ça peut
être l'entreprise individuelle
ça peut être l'entreprise individuelle à
responsabilité limitée
ça peut être la sarl ça peut être la sas
et c'est vrai également pour les
professions libérales et laon pour
arbitrer entre la base sert le revenu et
puis l'argent je laisse de côté si je
suis soumis à l'impôt société c'est pas
du tout le même régime
si je suis ce qu'on appelle en
transparence fiscale c'est-à-dire en bnc
ou ambeis et où si je suis soumis à
l'impôt société
donc je trouve cet article iv est un bon
article parce que il donne une
visibilité
ensuite on revient à l'article 21 sur
les modalités de calcul et là je sais
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de critiques sur
les ordonnances mais ça me semble
nécessaire c'est un vrai débat technique
qui va ce qui va ce sourire peu par
rapport à nous donc je crois que moi
encore une fois je parle parfois de mon
expérience mais j'ai accompagné pendant
des années des commerçants les artisans
et j'ai vu l'évolution leur façon de
fonctionner et je crois qu'on sait pas
du tout que ce que sera les modes
d'exercice plus tard mais on sent bien
une tendance
d'ailleurs le plfss il ya quelques
années avait un peu retoqué des formes
d'optimisation les gens se payer de
toute petite rémunération
et puis allez sur les distributions
dividendes et on a taxé les
distributions de dividendes
parce que c'était une forme détournée de
ne pas payer de cotisations sociales je
crois que
france se concentrer sur les ordonnances
parce qu'elles sont technique est
nécessaire
je crois que c'est un bon régime mais
qui est pas simple qui est pas simple et
je crois que on n'a pas fini de débattre
sur sur ces sujets et moi j'attends avec
impatience et ordonnances qui seront
négociés et qui seront travaillées sur
le fond madame motard s'est amusé en
entendant parlementaire qui attend avec
impatience des ordonnances pour être
éclairé sur le contenu de la loi no no
honey honnêtement c'est assez cocasse
alors effectivement nous sommes allés à
la page 146 et honnêtement l'éclairage
est très très relatifs monsieur le
ministre je relis la phrase qui est élu
par notre collègue la nouvelle assiette
des prélèvements sociaux des
indépendants correspondra aux revenus
super brut c'est à dire
asseyez-vous bien les revenus
professionnels retenue avant déduction
des cotisations sociales obligatoires et
la part des ducs type de la csg diminué
d'un abattement forfaitaire la question
concrète que la question concrète que
nous vous repose on sait quelle est la
différence en pourcentage qu'on puisse
être éclairé et je vous signale deux
choses c'est que les deux exemples qui
sont donnés dans l'étude d'impact
concerne les artisans en effet qu'ils
n'ont pas le même taux aujourd'hui de
cotisations vieillesse que par exemple
des avocats ou des médecins et les auto
entrepreneurs vous garantissez d'une
phrase d'une phrase que le la différence
entre la baisse de la csg et la hausse
des cotisations vieillesse sera neutre
d'une phrase il n'y a aucun exemple ni
sur les avocats ni pour lui ni sion les
médecins donc je n'estime pas que ces
deux pages soit de nature à nous
éclairer et je vous informe quand même
que et les avocats et les médecins ont
décidé de rendre au mois de mars
leurs propres projections leurs propres
projections
parce que l'étude d'impact de a à z est
truffé de bié qui ne permettent pas
d'éclairer véritablement ne débat parce
que l'âge d'équilibré y est fixé à 65
ans parce que là le taux de croissance
il est figé advitam eternam à 1,3 pour
cent et parce que vous prenez des
exemples qui sont des exemples parfois à
faire sourire comme cette infirmière qui
gagne 2500 euros par mois donc autant
vous dire que tout cela n'est pas parole
d'évangile pour le dira
monsieur dufrègne oui monsieur le
président moi aussi je suis content
qu'on parle des artisans et des
commerçants et je voulais souligner
toute la difficulté qu'ont aujourd'hui
les artisans et les commerçants
notamment en milieu rural
parce que ils ont souvent des activités
qui sont peu rémunératrice et d'ailleurs
on voit bien toute la difficulté qu'on
peut avoir aujourd'hui pour transmettre
un commerce et contrairement à hier
la notion de fonds de commerce à existe
de moins en moins parce que finalement
la valeur d'un fonds de commerce c'est
ça c'est sa rentabilité c'est à dire
combien ça va nous rapporter par rapport
à ce que nous allons investir et donc la
ce ces métiers qui sont de moins en
moins attractif et bien le seront encore
moins parce qu'on va sur des faibles
revenus demandé plus de cotisations et
je pense pas qu'on puisse se satisfaire
de dire que en contrepartie
eh bien on leur assure 85% du smic 85%
du smic et c'est mieux c'est mieux que
800 euros mais qui ici souhaiterait
vivre avec 1000 euros de retraite c'est
pour ça que finalement cette fameuse
conférence de financement nous
souhaitions qu'elle soit en amont que
nous souhaitions que nous puissions
définir les moyens que nous avions
consacré à cette réforme des retraites
parce que aujourd'hui finalement
eh bien on enferme les moyens et puis on
veut faire semblant d'être généreux la
générosité pour vous c'est 85% du smic
est-ce que vous accepteriez pour vous
même cette fameuse générosité
merci monsieur solignac pu m'appuyer
merci monsieur le président deux choses
d'abord pour rappeler aux rapporteurs et
monsieur le ministre que si nous
déposons les amendements de suppression
c'est parce que il s'agit de du seul
moyen pour nous de faire valoir un
certain nombre de sujets dès lors que
les amendements que nous pourrions
présenter serez frappés de l'article 40
donc il ne s'agit pas de dire qu'il faut
sortir les artisans du système du futur
système tel que vous voulez le
construire moi je souhaite qu'ils soient
dans un système universel généreux or je
suis extrêmement étonné de la réponse
que vous nous avez fait monsieur le
ministre puisque vous avez répondu sur
85% du smig
mais je veux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui un
artisan sa retraite de droit direct pour
quelqu'un qui a une carrière complète
ses 85 % du smic c'est 85% du smic donc
vous êtes en train de leur dire que vous
leur promettez ceux qui l'ont déjà
c'est-à-dire une maigre maigre pension
vous êtes en train de leur dire que
votre système ne produira pas plus alors
même qu'ils vont devoir cotiser plus et
la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi tant de mystère sur ses
ordonnances
il y à home hertha sur les ordonnances
si nous ne pouvons pas aujourd'hui
connaître vos intentions monsieur le
ministre je vous ai juste interrogé
là-dessus quelles sont vos intentions
vous avez dit publiquement la nécessité
de procéder par un lissage
mais qu'est ce qu'il y avait derrière ce
lissage allez-vous faire appel aux
réserves de certaines caisses oui ou non
comment allez vous le faire
répondez à ça les artisans veulent le
savoir est par ailleurs donné peut-être
des perspectives un peu plus positive
que le statu quo pour les commerçants et
les artisans la retraite your merci
merci monsieur ollier à la parole tip
merci monsieur le président bien puisque
l'on parle des artisans les indépendants
et leurs cotisations niveau leurs
cotisations d'abord je veux vous dire
que pour ceux qui ont eu la chance ou
l'opportunité de gérer une entreprise
c'est très clair la façon dont seront
calculées les assiettes d'abord le
revenu sera super brut ensuite on abat
les cotisations sociales ensuite on abat
la csg ensuite on abat les déductibilité
et on obtient le revenu sur lequel on a
la cotisation qui s'applique tout le
monde qui a eu à gérer une entreprise
ici c'est ce que ça veut dire et puis
ensuite vous nous dit
effectivement les cotisations elles vont
augmenter pour ce qui concerne la
cotisation vieillesse
oui c'est écrit dans le projet par
contre ce que vous ne dites pas parce
que l'étude d'impact vous la ligue parce
que vous la lisez et partiellement c'est
que les non-salariés gagneront 04
milliards d'euros avec cette hypothèse
il acquitteront 2,2 milliards de
prélèvements cotisations retraite
supplémentaire certes mais ils auront
une déductibilité de 2,6 milliards
d'euros de cotisations ou de
prélèvements sociaux et donc ils sont
gagnants et elles sont gagnants sur les
cotisations qu'ils paieront en moins
d'une part mais ils sont aussi gagnant
sur les droits qu'ils auront en plus il
ça c'est ce que nous vous disons nous
sur l'assurance d'avoir un minimum
contributif c'est à dire un minimum de
pension de 85% du smic qui est à mille
euros en 2022 mais qui est ensuite à
1147 euros en 2025 et donc sur ces
questions là pardon nous dire que c'est
moins de cotisations et plus de droits
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
[Applaudissements]
juste quelques quelques remarques à bord
propos que j'ai pu entendre
chers collègues solignac à aucun moment
la venue l'idée de remettre en question
la sincérité de votre démarche en tout
cas tout ce que vous portez sur les
commerçants et les artisans juste de
précision tout de même il y aura donc
comme l'a dit le ministre pas de hausses
de cotisations 1 pour les commerçants
les artisans
par ailleurs juste pour une question de
procédure sur les cotisations on peut
bien entendu amendé par contre il faut
gager dessus mais il n'y a pas de sujet
article 40 sur ce point là
par ailleurs chers collègues clémentine
autain pour la sincérité de nos débats
et par rapport à l'étude d'impact sur ce
qu'on trouve dans l'étude d'impact pour
chaque profession libérale pour toutes
les professions libérales quiros et aux
alentours des apps des pages 440 dans
l'étude d'impact
on trouve bien entendu à différents
niveaux de revenus le point sur les
cotisations actuelles sur le calcul en
euros sur le calcul en pourcentage
tout y est donc on ne peut pas je ne
peux pas laisser dire que ça ne l'est
pas et qu' il n'y a aucun point sur les
professions d'avocat les médecins les
notaires ainsi pas tout y est dans cette
étude d'impact chômage merci nous allons
donc voter sur le 24 1936 qui fait
l'objet d'un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement
un vote à main levée qui est pour
l'adoption qui est content je peux
thivel me rappelle le règlement sur la
base 58 fait personnel je refuse qu'on
dise qu'il est cocasse et convoque le
parlement dans son rôle de ratification
des ordonnances
voilà le parlement va travailler sur la
ratification de ces ordonnances ce ne
sont pas des décrets et notre collègue a
expliqué que c'étaient des éléments très
technique voilà le but des personnes
établies un bon sinon il va même se
moque de mons le règlement
je prie d'en haut au titre un rappel au
titre de l'article 100 pour vais vous
nous donnez vous ne l'avez pas fait tout
à l'heure le nombre d'amendements qu'ils
restent aujourd'hui à examiner nous
préciser si dans l'heure qui vient de se
passer nous n'avons vu effectivement le
vote vient d'intervenir que dit cet
amendement et si il nous resterait 183
jours de débats pour arriver au bout du
texte parce que moi je suggère à nos
oppositions d'enlever tous les
amendements en doublant voire triplant
pour que nous puissions enfin avancer
alors mon cher mon cher collègue pour ce
qui est du nombre d'amendements restant
je vous en fais pas grief parce que moi
aussi j'ai parfois des soucis avec la
lecture de la tablette
c'est marqué sur la tablette c'est
marqué en rouge vous avez vous avez à
quelque chose là et là il en rêve 31
1211 c'est accessible à tout le monde
n'y a pas besoin de le demander c'est
accessible à tout le monde mais nous
notre tâche c'est d'avancer et on va
continuer à avancer
c'est l'honneur du parlement d'essayer
de poursuivre le débat donc nous allons
poursuivre et nous allons poursuivre par
un rappel au règlement monsieur mille
francs tu veux sur le président hu est
il faut arrêter les appels au crime en
permanence euh ya des questionnements
qui sont clairement explicitées par les
oppositions d'ailleurs les rapporteurs
le rapporteur et le ministre vienne au
fond de ces amendements sur la question
par exemple des retraites des
commerçants arrêtez s'il vous plaît de
faire monter la sauce de faire monter la
sauce dans l'hémicycle nous sommes sur
un débat qui se déploie normalement qui
se déploie normalement et vous avez là
49,3 dans toutes vos têtes
mais prenez l'air prenez l'air et on
continue le débat tranquillement on
avance donc nous allons aborder le 1305
et je précise que le nom de la france a
soumis une demande du scrutin public
sera organisé le scrutin est annoncée
dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
qui présente le 13 1551 monsieur
coquerel vous avez la parole
oui je veux redire sur cette question de
csg parce que figurez-vous hier on a
reçu vous savez une délégation d'avocats
il n'y a pas que les avocats qui pose la
question parmi eux yves et comme quatre
bateliers
on peut parler de la représentativité de
ce que vous voulez mais il est cadre
d'ateliers qui étaient là qui se pose
des questions et je pense que les gens
écoutent nos débats
donc tant mieux aussi par rapport aux
questions que vous nous posez que nous
vous posons par contre ça éclaircit
certaines choses que manifestement vous
n'avez pas été capable d'éclaircir
jusqu'à maintenant dans les discussions
avec eux donc je reviens
le problème qui se pose par rapport par
rapport aux professions indépendantes si
finalement la même chose que par rapport
aux enseignants quand vous avez pris des
mesures vis-à-vis des fonctionnaires et
que vous êtes aperçu ça que ça les ailes
et les enseignants vous avez inventé la
question prendre en compte les clés les
primes qui seront définies dans une loi
ultérieure ce que certainement le
conseil constitutionnel n'a accepterait
pas donc en gros vous avez créé un
problème et vous y répondez en dehors de
la loi et en dehors même des cotisations
là c'est pareil
vous vous augmenter les cotisations vous
dites quand même effectivement la
manière dont on augmente les cotisations
en les doublant ça va poser un problème
et donc au lieu de résoudre ça sur la
question des cotisations vous le réseau
levé sur la question du 16 la csg
autrement dit par rapport à quelque
chose qui se calculent soit un revenu
net vous le faites sur la revenu le
revenu brut est super brut dont vous
parlez vous conviendrez déjà que ça
complique y fit beaucoup les choses ça
complexifie beaucoup les choses parce
que ben par essence la csg elle elle
peut être remise il comprit en question
au niveau des taux et c'est dans une loi
qui est indépendante de celle là et de
tamouls plfss
et en plus de ça ça pose deux questions
se posent des questions moins je pourrai
vous savez une chose le cnpf c'est la
déclaration du sud le cndf explique si
on raisonne globalement une manière
simplifiée en tenant compte de
l'application de l'abattement de 30% sur
le super brut et en retenant le shield
gouvernement d'une hausse d'environ 6%
alors apparemment monsieur le ministre
ça c'est quelque chose qui a été annoncé
pourriez vous nous confirmez de
cotisations non compensés cela équivaut
à 40 % de hausse de cotisations cnbf
c'est à dire que ces 6 par rapport à 14
soit 280 millions d'euros de cotisations
retraite par an pour la profession donc
ça c'est évidemment quelque chose
d'important parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
malgré ce que vous êtes en train
d'avancer cela ne compensera pas en
réalité l'augmentation des cotisations
donc je pense que ça serait intéressant
vous répondez à cette question 6 points
merci et scott shriner général
paroles et favori du ministre t'auras
porte à jamais donc voilà ma à une
question
oui merci monsieur le président donc
nous sommes à un moment de suppression
de l'alinéa 5 qui est une phrase général
je tiens d'abord à souligner la
créativité de nos oppositions
particulier celle de gauche puisqu'on a
un coût supprimé l'année à 5 supprimé
l'année à 6 sur près d'une assiette mais
on a aussi supprimé la nina 5 à 6 5 6 et
7 5 à 8 donc des combinaisons sans fin
qui sont assez intéressantes
cela dit vous ne les avez pas toutes
explorées et en 2006 il y avait avec la
privatisation de gdf 130 mille
amendements d'obstruction délibéré
assumer comme vous juste pour bloquer le
texte
est ce qu'il faut vous faut mes chers
collègues et assumez-le vous êtes là
pour vous opposez vous utilisez des
outils
je déplore pour la démocratie que vous
utilisiez l'obstruction parlementaire
mais c'est précisément ce que vous
faites et si nous revenons sur 2006 au
bout d'à peu près 10 12 jours là nous en
sommes une fois que le président debré
avait écrit aux présidents de groupes
d'opposition qu'ils étaient en train de
remettre en question la démocratie
parlementaire une fois que les français
avaient compris le message
mais au final n'y avait pas adhéré cette
obstruction ce n'est pas ce qu'ils
attendaient des parlementaires enfin une
fois que les français voulaient qu'on
ait le débat sur le fond les groupes
d'opposition de gauche parti socialiste
et communiquent et communistes ont
accepté de défendre les amendements par
centaines pour pouvoir aller au bout du
texte pour ne pas avoir le 49 3 et cela
s'est fait en moins de trois semaines
c'est donc tout à fait possible cela
dépend uniquement de flux
et je vous invite à vous comporter de la
même manière responsabilité vis-à-vis
des français
mais qui est le président heures vous
avez la parole je crois que le président
et plusieurs ou plusieurs discussions
encore un nouveau sur la forme du débat
je veux dire à notre collègue madame de
lavernhe que vous avez raison il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'amendements sur le
texte que vous avez cités plus de 100000
mais il ya pas eu de 49,3 enfin je crois
moi que je me trompe mais il n'y a plus
qu'un seul point
on est allé en est allé en est allé
jusqu'au bout des choses
donc le gouvernement de l'époque a pris
beaucoup de temps on est allé jusqu'au
bout des choses et au fond c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut faire donc il
faut aller jusqu'au bout des choses de
ceux de ce texte parce que parce que
parce qu'il pense que c'est nécessaire
parce que c'est nécessaire mais ce n'ai
aucun problème trois semaines ça ne pose
que vous n'avez aucun texte majeur qui
suivent donc ça ne pose aucun problème
ce texte est fondamentale s'il faut
trois semaines s'il faut un mois pour
répondre à deux ans d'une concertation
et d'une préparation pour le moins
insatisfaisante de ce texte
rectifions le ici vous avez d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'amendements de rectification
qu'il faut absolument prendre en compte
pas uniquement dans 1 49 ans mais qui
vous prend en compte dans un débat
parlementaire et messieurs vu le frein
monsieur le président
concevez tout de même que depuis le
début de cette question posée par le
régime des retraites
vous avez en face de vous une opposition
et qu'elle est quelle est votre réponse
quelle est votre réponse et bien c'est
d'abord la langue de bois enfin par
rapport par rapport aux mouvements
sociaux qui ce qu'ils ont été engagés
qu'est ce que vous dites
les françaises sont prises en otage
l'économie va mal et dans la foulée
c'est les sanctions vous savez très bien
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple parce que ça
on n'en parle pas il ya 120 agents de la
ratp qui sont menacés de sanctions dans
l'entreprise vous avez également réuni
les conditions pour que alors qu'il ya
des cheminots majoritairement grève
cohérent quand 0 sur leurs feuilles de
paye
eh bien vous aligner une prime sur les
non-grévistes
voilà votre façon de provoquer la
population aujourd'hui et vis-à-vis du
parlement vous maniez les éternels
discours de l'obstruction vous refuser
le débat sur une réforme de fond qui
vise à faire travailler plus les
français plus longtemps avec moins de
pension alors souffrait souffre et que
nous ayons jusqu'au bout de ce débat et
ce au delà même des municipales où vous
allez où vous allez finalement récupérer
le vote des français dans les urnes et
nous ferons le compte au lendemain du 15
mars
merci alors monsieur juanico
diam's et le président puisqu'on est
sans cesse ramener à des questions de
procédure et l'examen de nos de nos
débats pourquoi normal parce que ça se
passe très bien depuis quelques jours
franchement donc c'est pas voyez le
rythme soutenu dans lequel on est le
nombre d'amendements que nous examinons
chaque heure franchement voilà moi j'ai
assisté à la quasi totalité la
commission spéciale à la quasi totalité
de la séance publique
franchement je n'ai qu'à me féliciter de
la qualité des échanges que nous avons
avec le rapporteur avec le ministre avec
un certain nombre de vos collègues qui
courageusement prennent la parole et
alimente le débat de fond et si vous
voulez faire écrire au président ferrand
aux présidents de groupes d'opposition
il n'a qu'à le faire comme l'a fait à
l'époque le président de l'assemblée
nationale monsieur debré on nous on a
écrit à monsieur ferron madame boyer
belloubet on a mis quinze jours à nous
répondre sur la commission denquête donc
on verra on examinera les choses mais on
n'est pas pressé et qu'on se voit un
certain nombre de mes collègues qui
défendent aujourd'hui les ordonnances
alors que pour le projet loi pas qu on a
vu qu'il ya une ordonnance de
ratification qui sera jamais examiné
notamment sur la création de l'autorité
nationale des jeux je serai je serai
très prudent sur la question des
ordonnances quand elles doivent revenir
aux ratifications par contre hier
on a eu un gouvernement qui a déposé un
amendement de cinq pages substantielle à
l'article 61 sur la période transitoire
donc on voit bien qu'on est toujours
dans ce processus de bricolage du projet
de loi en cours de route au doigt
mouillé le réforme du doigt mouillé et
que donc on fait notre boulot fait notre
boulot d'opposition aux poses des
questions et on demande au gouvernement
de préciser les choses
voilà il ça continuera et quand il y
aura de l'obstruction vous apercevrez la
différence monsieur matte et monsieur
matte et de d'abord oui comme vous chers
collègues j'ai eu le bonheur d'assister
un commission intégralement 75 heures on
siège depuis la semaine dernière
bon il faut objectivement on n'avance
pas normalement sur ce texte
moi je que je comprends que l'on puisse
monde et droit d'amendement c'est tout à
fait légitime et remarqué que souvent
les interventions elles sont sur le fond
et sont pas sur la forme
j'essaie d'éviter je crois que l'on
gagnerait effectivement en sérénité si
on arrivait à aller sur les amendements
essentiels la discussion sur l'article 4
et n'est pas neutre et quand je parle
des ordonnances c'est pas pour me me
défausser de de mon rôle de
parlementaire pas du tout je pense qu'il
ya des aspects techniques qu'il faut
accepter ses on et j'ai fait la
différence en commission entre décret
même s'il ya pas mal de décret dans ce
texte et et ordonnances l'avantagé
l'ordonnancé qu'elle ait ratifié alors
on est ou pas beaucoup pour ou contre
mais on a quand même
l'aval de l'assemblée vous en
conviendrez voilà moi je pense que c'est
très difficile d'avancer dans ce texte
c'est vrai que c'est gênant mais ce qui
me gêne le plus je vais vous dire ce qui
me gêne le plus c'est les temps de
parole parce que franchement c'est
déséquilibré le temps de parole vous
parler sur chaque amendement
vous avez un temps de parole et je pense
que là on a un problème de démocratie de
deux je dirais d'équité dans cette dans
cet hémicycle on entend en boucle les
arguments et le temps de parole de la
majorité qui devient entre guillemets
presque l'opposition au niveau des temps
de parole me gêne un peu
si monsieur coquerel bon j'ai pas
revenir sur les interventions d'une
majorité capricieuse qui estime que les
choses ne vont pas assez vite dans le
calendrier qu'elle avait défini qu'elle
avait défini moi ce que j'observe
simplement c'est que si le gouvernement
ne répond pas parce que vous défendez
cette loi au lieu de faire les
interventions que vous faites vous
pourriez nous répondre peut-être que
vous vous avez les arguments pour nous
répondre et répondre encore une fois à
des métiers et des métiers des
professions qui sont en lutte donc je
repose ma question parce qu'encore une
fois en l'occurrence nous sommes dans le
débat de fond vous avez parlé 30 %
d'abattement sur le super brut
monsieur le ministre je vous demande de
me confirmer le chiffre avancé par le
cnpf très certainement un chiffre qui à
l'issue de leurs discussions que la
hausse non compensés serait d'environ 6
% de cotisations non compensés au lieu
des 28 annoncé par rapport à cet
abattement c'est ce que apparemment vous
avez dit ce qui équivaut encore une fois
là c'est juste les chiffes le rapport de
pourcentage entre 6 et entre 6 et 14 à
40 % de hausse des cotisations cnbf ses
280 millions d'euros
voilà 280 millions d'euros qui seront
sur une période indéterminée à compter
donc vous comprenez bien que la question
que je pose là elle concerne évidemment
elle a un impact financier sur les
professions et je trouve légitime
à partir du moment où l'article 21 et
part en dose d'ailleurs ce site où tu
étais lecture étude d'impact je
comprends pas très bien que vous
renvoyer à l'ordonnancé un peu
contradictoire ce qui montre bien que
c'est pas si clair mais comme c'est
quelque chose qui qui sera déterminée
par an donne ans vous avez l'air de dire
que les réponses sont précis est ce que
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez
répondre aux chiffres que je vous donne
et qu'ils font quand même un trou de 280
millions d'euros
si c'est les chiffres qui correspond je
pense qu'à des professions qui seront
écoute intéressés d'avoir votre réponse
ici merci nous allons procéder au vote
un vote électronique chacun peut
regagner sa place
nous votons sur le 13 mille cinq cent
soixante et un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement un scrutin
est ouvert
un scrutin est clos voici les résultats
vote en conseil mais 89 majorité 45 pour
12 contre 77
l'amendement est rejeté nous venons
13500 sont 18 qui helmand fera l'objet
d'un vote électronique événements du
groupe la france a soumise au scrutin
est annoncée dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale vous avez la
parole
madame motta oui merci monsieur le
président un amendement de suppression
qui continue mais je voudrais répondre à
mes collègues sur en effet ce temps
passé maintenant à débattre de la
méthode et de est-ce qu'on va aller
jusqu'au bout ce qui fait que la menace
du quart entre 9,3 en fait elle pénalise
complètement le débat parce que elle
nous empêche de savoir jusqu'où on va y
aller votre faute
votre fente pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que vous avez dépassé les
délais pour le temps légal programme et
ensuite parce que vous n'écoutez pas
l'état de la société si nous parlons
démocratie pour nous interpeller là
dessus
si nous parlons de démocratie vous vous
trouvez que c'est tout à fait logique
que une loi soit votée par le parlement
alors qu'elle est rejetée par la
majorité des français et qu'elle suscite
et qu'elle suscite et qu'elle suscite un
état de colère massive dans le pays
produisant une mobilisation sociale à la
durée et à l'ampleur totalement
totalement inédite totalement inédite
donc si vous n'entendez rien de cela et
que vous pensez que vous êtes en tous
points parfaitement légitime
fort bien mais comprenez que nous
opposition politique
nous n'avons pas décidé de nous taire de
vous faciliter la tâche d'accepter je ne
sais quel compromis de remettre nos
amendements nous son amendement au
placard parce que cela vous embête et
d'arrêter de poser des questions parce
que vous me répondez pas et qu'il
faudrait que une fois qu'on l'a posée
même si vous ne répondez pas on rentre
tranquillement chez nous
comprenez que ça n'est pas possible de
débattre comme ça c'est pas possible
absolument pas possible et l'enjeu qui
nous est posée est un enjeu de
démocratie parce qu'en effet c'est un
symptôme du dysfonctionnement de cette
vème république
j'espère que vous le comprenez c'est un
symptôme et c'est pourquoi nous
proposons d'aller vers une nouvelle
république parce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas à ça vous énerve
[Applaudissements]
nom laisse pas la motta conclure on
laisse madame en fait conclure chef
pardonnez moi je comprends pas ce qui
chiffonne jory t de cette assemblée
dès lors que je dis que nous voulons une
sixième république ce qui est quand même
pas un scoop
nous l'avons dit c'est notre proposition
politique on y tient et je pense qu'on
ne serait pas dans un tel déni de
démocratie
si nous avions des fonctionnement
institutionnel qui soient davantage
raccord avec l'exigence de participation
de la volonté citoyenne à la décision
publique
merci monsieur le rapporteur j'ai dit
merci pour ce discours politique mais
l'amendement n'a pas été présentée sur
le fond si ce sera la demande un avis
défavorable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le président merci ce sujet
suppression de l'alinéa rentrer encore
une fois l'article incohérent donc j'ai
un avis défavorable
merci et un à paroles oui merci monsieur
le président moi je veux vraiment là je
commande
je suis extrêmement surprise qu'à chaque
amendement défendu par les groupes de
gauche ça ressemble à un meeting
politique
on n'est pas dans un meeting politique
on est en train d'étudier un projet de
loi retraites qui va toucher des
millions deux millions de françaises et
de français
quand vous alors vous contestez
l'obstruction vous contester le fait que
vous transformiez cette assemblée en
meeting politique
pouvez vous m'expliquer pourquoi madame
autun votre amendement 13 1578 parle de
supprimer l'alinéa 6 le 13 1579 de
monsieur bernalicis parle de supprimer
l'alinéa 6 monsieur coquerel le train 13
1580 parle de supprimer
l'alinéa 6 monsieur corbières le 13 1581
parle de supprimer 9
l'alinéa 6 et ainsi de suite surtout les
membres de votre groupe
donc cette inadmissible l'obstruction
elle est là nous voulons débattre nous
sommes là nous sommes patients nous ne
souffrons pas monsieur villefranque nous
ne souffrons pas du débat mais nous
aimerions enfin y arriver et vous nous
empêchez d'arriver au débat de fond ne
faites pas croire aux français qu'il
s'agit d'un débat de fond
vous avez transfert vous avez transformé
cet hémicycle en meeting politique et il
est temps de le dénoncer
voilà
[Applaudissements]
madame madame autant madame autant votre
monsieur petit à la parole
[Musique]
monsieur possible des comprimés où je
passe d'abord avec quelqu'un d'autre
monsieur petit merci mais nous exprimer
si monsieur le président madame boutin
maetur je parle madame boutin votre
position est celle de tous vos collègues
votre position est complètement légitime
elle est complètement légitime
vous avez le droit de vous opposer et
vous avez même le devoir de représenter
dans cet hémicycle
non seulement les citoyens qui vous ont
élu mais également ceux qui m'ont élu
comme moi je représente les citoyens qui
vous ont élus
votre position est légitime comprenez
qu'on soit un peu déstabilisé je vais
venir sur le fond pourquoi pourquoi
votre côté et vous refusez de soutenir
le passage de 1 passe à 3 passes si vous
prétendez soutenir les positions qui
sont les vôtres
alors que cette mesure ramène dans le
régime général tout 99% des hauts
salaires et 99 cent des personnes et 97%
des hauts salaires
c'est là plus que sur la répétition est
sûre le tout ce que vous dites sur le
fait qu on vous répond pas alors qu'on
vous ai déjà répondu 25 fois quand vous
n'étiez pas là nous n'étions là on a
répondu à vos collègues
on a répondu on a répondu tout le monde
répond mais plus que la répétition plus
que les amendements inutile ce qui me
choque profondément
c'est l'illogisme de ce que vous
reprochez c'est l'illogisme vous devriez
y compris pour les forces que vous
représentez vous devriez soutenir le
passage de l'impasse à trois passes
pourquoi ne pouvons nous pas au moins
dans un débat de parlementaires nous
mettre d'accord sur cette proposition du
texte parce que il suffit d'amendé il
suffit d'amendé correctement aux lieux
d'amendé avec des logorrhées vous auriez
choisi quatre ou cinq amendements qui
confirmait qui passait à 5 passes qui
passait à lui passe si vous voulez mais
selon d'amendements ça aurait fait un
débat où vous auriez regagner votre
légitimité d'opposition alors que là
c'est vous qui fragilise est votre
légitimité
[Applaudissements]
madame dalloz
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
à ce stade de notre débat rappeler à la
majorité que le temps de parole de
l'opposition surtout les textes est
toujours supérieur à celui du temps de
parole de la majorité ne vous en
déplaise c'est le principe de la
démocratie
c'est comme ça que ça existe parce que
je vous le rappelle encore une fois le
texte c'est au texte du gouvernement
avec lequel vous avez travaillé qui lie
à pour porter la voix de la majorité
leur rapporteur général et pléthore de
rapporteur vous avez quand même quatre
rapporteurs
parallèlement rapporteur général vous
avez qui plus est le ministre qui est
aussi qui représente la parole de votre
majorité
et vous avez la présidente de commission
et vous avez deux groupes dans la
majorité
donc si avec tout ça vous n'arrivez pas
à considérer que les autres ont un peu
le droit d'expression dans quel débat
sommes nous dans quel hémicycle nous
sommes nous premier aspect deuxièmement
madame et vous citer tous les
amendements vous égrainé les amendements
de la série d'amendements enfin c'est
pas une nouveauté ça fait deux ans et
demi vous siégez ici bientôt vous savez
que chaque série d'amendements ce sont
des série d'amendements déposés par un
groupe sont rigoureusement identiques
rigoureusement identique c'est vous
c'est votre majorité qui avait modifié
le règlement qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya plus qu une défense il est défendu
une seule fois dans le passé moi j'ai
connu des amendements des série
d'amendements qu'ils étaient tous
défendus vous avez déjà largement amputé
le temps de parole de chacune et chacun
puisqu'il ya un seul amendement défendu
par série enfin j'entends monsieur petit
nous dire que la majorité est
déstabilisé on en avait pas douter mais
vous êtes déstabiliser de peu
merci monsieur bul fort merci monsieur
le président dans un débat aussi
fondamental pour les français dans un
débat aussi fondamental pour les
français que n'avez vous pas que n'avez
vous pas retenu la demande que nous vous
avons exposé avec plusieurs groupes
d'opposition de passer par référendum la
est à la fois le débat devant les
français le débat légitime
avec les points de vue défendu par votre
majorité est le point de vue défendu par
les oppositions par rapport à un texte
qu'ils auraient convenu de décrypter
davantage encore aux yeux des français
puisque semble-t-il vous ne parvenez pas
à le décrypter en votre faveur par
rapport aux contacts que vous avez
déployés depuis deux ans et demi avec
les organisations syndicales et les
organisations professionnelles et les
français trancherait ce débat le
trancherait en connaissances en
éclairage et lent que ce que nous vous
disons c'est qu'à votre 49,3 qui va
pointer demain après-demain dans deux
trois jours
choisissez la voie de la sagesse et
ouvrait droit à une consultation au fond
par les français éclairez effectivement
des sensibilités que sont l'or
l'ensemble de leurs députés et mala
matin oui merci monsieur président
d'abord une première réponse sur le
nombre d'amendements vous avez en effet
modifier la règle qui fait qu'on peut
multiplier par dix sept c'est à dire le
nombre de personnes de notre groupe
ici
on ne peut le défendre qu'une seule fois
donc de toutes façons le x 10 7 ne joue
pas dans l'assemblée ici premièrement
deuxièmement monsieur petit vous
m'interpeller sur l'histoire de 1 passe
à 3 passe je ne sais pas exactement à
quoi vous faites référence parce que
c'était pas le débat de l'arctique ce
n'est pas le débat de l'amendement en
question et que par ailleurs et que par
ailleurs
en effet même si à un moment donné on
devra discuter d'un tout petit bout
potentiel d'amélioration ce qui n'est
pas le cas je ne sais pas de quoi vous
parlez d'un tout petit bout
d'amélioration nous ne sommes pas là
pour améliorer le texte
nous ne sommes là pour vous dire que
nous ne voulons pas d'un régime par
points qui va baisser le niveau des
pensions et a logé la durée de
cotisation donc après un intérieur
l'enjeu pour nous n'est pas de savoir si
on va essayé de temporiser de faire que
ça soit moins dramatique que la casse
monstrueuse que vous êtes en train de
préparer pour notre régime de retraite
nous sommes là pour faire valoir un
point de vue qui est que nous nous
opposons comme la majorité des français
à l'instauration de votre projet sur les
réformes
et enfin pour ce qui est de ce matin je
vous signale que nous avons posé un
certain nombre de questions sur
lesquelles nous n'avons toujours pas de
réponse
j'ai demandé au ministre de nous dire
très précisément sur la caisse des
avocats ou des médecins est-ce que vous
engagez à dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
ponction sur ses caisses pour non non
non il a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'expropriation écoutez bien monsieur
petit ne fait pas le bisounours
écoutez bien monsieur petit monsieur
petit insulter mon groupe dans une
tribune en nous traitant de bisounours
et de stalinien je lui renvoie le
compliment ici dans cette c1 leurs gains
peu de calme nous allons donc voter sur
l'amendement avis défavorable la
commission a dû vers nantes à voter
électroniques
[Musique]
m
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin clôt
votants 94 à 1119 majorité 40 pour 9
contre 70 l'amendement est donc rejetée
mais jacques l'aide d'un moment
d'attention s'il vous plaît avant de
donner la parole pour l'amendement
suivant je voudrais évoquer quelque
chose que je trouve inadmissible
notre collègue ici présente madame
iborra s'est permis par tweet de
contester ma présidence
d'abord c'est quelque peu pas courageux
parce qu'on est en droit de prendre la
parole
deuxièmement elle contexte le président
la façon suivante elle dit marc le fur
vice-président et l'air je suis pas et
l'air ici je suis vice président c'est
tout et je n'ai pas l'intention de faire
autre chose et d'autre part vous
impliquer dans votre tweet que je ne
commande pas les amendements de
l'opposition
ma fonction n'est pas de commenter les
amendements ma chère collègue
absolument pas
vous pouvez répondre pour vous excuser
j'imagine
monsieur le président en effet vous
n'avez pas l'habitude de contester ou de
commenter le contenu des amendements des
pommes avant mais vous n'avez pas non
plus l'habitude de déclarer que nous
faisons que notre assemblée vote des
amendements à cent à l'heure
vous n'avez pas non plus l'habitude de
ce genre plus de wecan et tout en
respectant votre présidence
on est en droit nous de se poser la
question de savoir pourquoi en effet
aujourd'hui dans le contexte dans lequel
nous votons aujourd'hui vous signalez
finalement que nous sommes nous
pourrions être jugée sur la vitesse à
laquelle nous adoptons les amendements
je trouve que ce n'est pas normal
venant du grand chocolat je suis
président depuis 12 ans je suis dans
cette assemblée depuis 20 ans je suis
attaché cette institution et je ferai
tout pour en préserver le maximum de
sérénité
il est très fréquent d'indiquer le
rythme des amendements ça permet à tout
à chacun d'être tout à fait au fait des
choses
donc j'attends de vous des excuses en
attendant nos travaux sont suspendues
pour dix minutes
[Applaudissements]
là on commence
merci la séance et reprises
on va donner la parole à madame la
présidente monsieur président merci moi
je voulais que rappeler à ce moment du
débat que j'aimerais que la sérénité
revienne dans nos rangs quel qu'il soit
et que nous ne remettions pas en cause
sous des billets différents la
présidence quelle qu'elle soit parce que
je pense que depuis ce matin nous
pouvons saluer la présidence de monsieur
le fur qui a été tout à fait conforme à
ce qui doit se passer dans un hémicycle
tel que le nôtre donc d'abord je voulais
m'en excuser monsieur président parce
que je pense que c'est très important
pour la suite de nos débats et
j'aimerais que chacun reprenne le débat
sur le fond qu'il espère comme vous
voyez monsieur le président on en
parlait que madame genevard l'autre jour
franchement les réseaux sociaux n'ont
rien à faire dans cet hémicycle
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
j'apprécie beaucoup croient que tout a
été dit par la présidente on va pouvoir
reprendre gentil gentiment jouer tout a
été dit donc
l'incident est clos d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas eu d'incident l'incident est clos on
reprend nos débats sereinement calmement
comme il faut pour essayer de les faire
un peu progressé nous en venons donc
autres et 113 1595
s'il ya une demande de scrutin public et
la demande du groupe la france insoumise
le scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'assemblée nationale monsieur
coquerel vous avez la parole merci
excellent président c'est un amendement
sur la ligne à qui concerne le titre de
système universel dont je vous raconte
est contesté la véracité
mon autre parent d'une part il est dit
que en réalité seuls 75 % des
travailleurs indépendants cotiseront au
même niveau et un revenu identique
ouvrir grand les mêmes droits que les
retraites que les salariés ça ne
concerne donc pas l'ensemble des
indépendants mais surtout
il est noté qu' il est proposé que les
travailleurs indépendants cotisent
uniquement hauteur de la part salariale
des cotisations puisque ils cotisent
moins c'est dans le dans l'explication
de l'article les travailleurs
indépendants s'ouvrir au moins de droits
que les salariés ayant des revenus
identiques donc on s'aperçoit donc il
n'ya pas là de caractère universel au
sens propre
enfin dans l'article 22 on note
plusieurs choses par exemple une
assiette minimale de cotisation
maintenue au niveau actuel pour les
travailleurs indépendants d'un agricole
les ceci pour ce 1 demandé à s'acquitter
d'un montant de cotisation supérieure
afin d'acquérir plus de points ailleurs
une cotisation minimale plus fait pour
les exploitants agricoles que la
cotisation minimale actuelle mais les
cotisations versées par les chefs
d'exploitation chefs d'entreprises
devront s'acquitter d'un montant minimal
de cotisations qui sera déterminée par
décret qui paye la différence
possibilité pour les micro entrepreneurs
de s'inquiéter sur option d'un montant
de cotisations d'assurance vieillesse
égales soit la cotisation minimale soit
la cotisation minimale renforcée
autrement dit et ce qu'on n'ait pas
plutôt la dans un système d'universalité
de régimes de retraite à la carte
merci jacques lapart à général sur cet
amendement
avis défavorable monsieur ministre même
indique que le rapporte à monsieur le
président monsieur coquerel
j'observe donc qu'on soit précisément
sur l'article lui-même en posant des
questions soldes le caractère universel
à travers les exemples que j'aime de
cité où que l'on soit sur un amendement
concernant l'article
globalement sur la question de du super
brut et des difficultés de cotiser deux
des difficultés de compenser
d'augmentation de cotisations sur le net
part
une baie un abattement sur le super brut
on a la même réponse sans commentaire
manifestement quoi qu'on fasse de toute
façon les questions deviennent pas de la
part du gouvernement et du rapporteur je
regrette bien regagner sa place nous
allons donc voter sur le 13 1595
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats votants 117 exprimé
59 majorité 30 pour 6 contre 53
l'amendement n'est pas adopté madame
ménard pour le 74 14 et les défendu
madame antoine pour le
11 1878 identique non c'est moi excusez
moi monsieur le président à pardonner
nous l'avons déjà s'ils gagnent un
nombre un nombreuses reprises cette loi
n'a d'universel que le nom vous avez
créé cinq régimes spécifiques
donc soyons précis dans les termes et
supprimons simplement ce mot universel
donc l'amendement suivant il implique
les 11880 est défendue non monsieur
oui trente secondes je ne prends pas les
argumentations de ma collègue isabelle
valentin simplement je le défend avec
fierté parce qu'il est présenté par
notre excellent président je dis bien
excitant président marc le fur
et je le défend avec fierté alors sur
ces amendements
merci beaucoup pour ce sujet totalement
nouveaux avis défavorable oui monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président
franchement le débat sur l'universel ou
pas on est déjà eu je peux vous redire
encore une fois un mot si vous voulez
hein
le système est universel et il comprend
plusieurs régimes voilà c'est c'est
carbonneau dit d'ailleurs du projet de
loi c'est le système universel de
retraite défavorable merci défavorable
jamais donc voici un amendement
identique y est pour contre rejeté alors
un amendement de 24 1937 24 1937
monsieur genicot merci merci monsieur le
président merci d'avoir ramené la
sérénité
madame la présidente de la commission
brigitte bourguignon avec l'aide de tous
les groupes
je connais marc lefur depuis près de dix
ans en tant que président de séance
je n'ai jamais pris en défaut de
partialité voilà je tenais à vous le
dire très calmement nous ne sommes pas
tout à fait du même bord non on
commençait à s'inquiéter
on commençait à s'inquiéter tout à
l'heure sur la multiplication des des
prises de parole qui se succédaient des
députés de la majorité
pendant près d'une heure et qui était
relative à la soi-disante obstruction de
l'opposition
on aurait pu comprendre ses prises de
parole comme la préparation du terrain
pour l'éruption imminente tel blücher à
waterloo d'un membre du gouvernement
venant annoncer le 49-3 mais non la
menace est écartée et j'en viens à
l'amendement monsieur le président je
crois qu'il ya une faute dans le
finalement que nous voulons corriger à
traverser c'est un moment c'est un
amendement au rédactionnel qui vise à
corriger une petite erreur du
gouvernement alors certes involontaire
et qui vise à supprimer le terme
universel pour le remplacer par celui
plus adaptée de retraite par points si
mesuré à porter merci la présentation
est habile mais ce débat nous l'avons
eue à multiples reprises j'ai moi même
déjà plusieurs fois répondu aussi avis
défavorable à pardonnez moi j'avais des
sous-amendements le 42e 515 monsieur
brunel merci monsieur le président j'en
profite également pour vous affirmer
tout le soutien solidarité du groupe gdr
en tant que vice président de
l'assemblée nationale
ce sous-amendement donc c'est un moment
de précision qui vise à rappeler la
conséquence insidieuse cette réforme des
retraites sur le montant des pensions de
retraite de nos concitoyens en effet
comme
l'avait bien dit françois fillon 2016
mes chers collègues le système par
points en réalité permet une chose
qu'aucun homme politique n'a vous il
permet de baisser chaque année la valeur
des points et donc de diminuer le niveau
des pensions il ment un autre
sous-amendement le 42 577
oui monsieur le président et ce sous
amendement de précision vise à rappeler
aussi l'un des objectifs insidieux de
cette réforme des retraites
quand on imposer le gouvernement à nos
concitoyens celui du développement des
retraites par capitalisation
avec cette réforme le gouvernement
cherche acclimater les ménages à une
épargne retraite individualisé pose les
bases d'un système de retraite par
capitalisation c'est pour ça que nous
proposons d'un third instauré après le
mot points le mot le terme et par
capitalisation
merci sur ces thèmes mandement et ces
sous-amendements j'ai à partager un
défavorable monsieur le ministre
et ma victoire à bordeaux président ou
jamais donc voit tout d'abord le
sous-amendement le premier
sous-amendement le 40 2575 qui est pour
contre jeter le 42 1517 qui est pour
quand rejetée nous voilà maintenant non
sous-amendé le 24 1937 qui est pour
contre jeter le 13 1613 madame aubenas
oui merci monsieur le président alors
c'est un amendement de suppression de
l'alinéa 8 nous continuons à vouloir à
vous proposer de supprimer ali n'est pas
alinéa par ligne les articles de ceux de
ce projet de loi et je crois que sur la
question des travailleurs et
travailleuses indépendant c'est
important de rappeler qu' on est dans
cette situation de mobilisation d'un
certain nombre de secteurs non pas parce
que les personnes concernées ne seraient
pas solidaire ou ne voudrais pas
participer à l'effort collectif ce qui
est a été montré dans les débats qu'on a
pu avoir hier par exemple sur les
caisses et autonome des des avocats qui
participent à l'effort collectif
je crois que la question y compris
malgré ce qu'a essayé de faire le
gouvernement et qui laissait toujours
d'opposer les catégories les unes aux
autres
la question c'est que vous voulez faire
converger un certain nombre de régimes
autonome auto régulée en équilibre vers
un système qui est du moins d'ici danse
sociale qui est une et dans le cas des
travailleurs et travailleurs
travailleurs et travailleuses
indépendantes qui va augmenter les
cotisations
avec la perspective d'une baisse de
pensions puisque ça va être le cas pour
l'ensemble de votre système
et donc on a là là à travers cet exemple
de ces secteurs en particulier à la
différence de ce que vous aviez pu
essayer de faire en pointant et en
stigmatisant par exemple les régimes
spéciaux où les fonctionnaires on a la
démonstration que votre projet de loi ne
satisfait a aucun corps de métier à
aucune catégorie de métiers oui nous
allons continuer chers collègues à le
montrer d'ailleurs si ce n'était que
nous vous pourriez toujours dire que on
radote
on répète les mêmes choses mais c'est ce
que vous répète et vous continuez à vous
interpeller sur ce sujet oui toutes les
professions qu'on a cité tous les
secteurs qui appelle à une mobilisation
dans quelques jours parce que votre
système n'est ni me versait ligne
égalitaire ni convergent vers le haut et
le mieux disant monsieur laporte
alinéa suppressions déjà doha monsieur
le ministre
même avis monsieur le président 27 358
n'est pas défendu nous venons aux 443
qui le défendent 40 53 le groupe ait
l'air et pardonnez moi n'a pas voté sur
le 13 113 1613 défavorable commission
gouvernement qui est pour quand
rejetée donc le 25 1358 pas défendue non
à pardonnez-moi pardonnez moi vous
réveillez pas massif reconnaît philippe
sella parole merci monsieur le président
cet amendement vise les avocats non
salariés
la disparité des situations avocats non
salarié demande à mon avis une période
de préparation préalable à l'intégration
au système de retraite universel
oui je suis favorable à notre réforme
qui pour moi est une grande réforme
sociale ça c'est clair en revanche
concernant les avocats il ne me semble
pas opportun qu'ils intègrent le système
universel dès maintenant pourquoi
à titre d'illustration si je prends le
barreau de rouen le barreau d'oran c510
avocat et sur ses 510 avocat afin khiem
a un revenu inférieur à 24000 euros
ses avocats qui ont de tels revenus ceux
ceux qui défendent les justiciables au
titre de l'aide juridictionnelle est
donc cette période de moratoire pour moi
serait indispensable afin de leur
laisser le temps de réfléchir à leur
modèle économique parce que lorsqu'on
fait une moyenne du revenu médian des
avocats moi je pense que c'est pas
important parce que certains avocats
gagnent même pas 1000 euros d'autres
gagnent 100 mille euros donc un revenu
médian
non ça ce n'est pas possible ensuite les
avocats ont subi plusieurs réformes
successives
donc il faut leur laisser le temps de
digérer toutes ces réformes successives
donc cet amendement pour moi c'est un
l'amendement de justice et c'est un
amendement en faveur des
des plus faibles merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues cias là cet amendement est
déjà satisfait en réalité puisque les
avocats ils rentreront à partir de 2000
du 1er janvier 2000 25 dans le système
universel en 2000 rentreront avant 2022
les personnes nées en 2004 environ 18
ans reconnaissons qu'il ya peu d'avocats
qui peut personnes qui deviennent
avocate à 18 ans donc dé facto votre
demande et déjà satisfaite aussi ce sera
une demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le président voilà je
cherchais du regard on avait la députée
oui en fait je relisais votre amendement
tranquillement vous en aviez parlé tout
à l'heure l'objet c'est d'intégrer tous
les avocats libéraux sur à compter de
2025 un chiffre regarde
en tout cas c'est l'objet de
l'amendement même si j'ai compris dans
votre propos il y avait peut-être un
petit peu de nuances bon si on va
tranquillement avancé dans le texte et
j'espère qu'on va s'accélérer bientôt on
verra dans l'article 63 qu'on a une
entrée en vigueur du système universel
de retraite en fonction de la génération
de naissance donc cette entrée en
vigueur générationnel va s'appliquer
aussi aux avocats ça fait un peu écho à
ce qu'a dit le rapportant tout à l'heure
mais je peux te faire plus dans le
détail c'est que les avocats qui sont
nés avant 75 seront pas concernés par ce
système universel mais je dirais comme
tout le monde c'est à dire que tous ceux
qui sont avancés génération seront pas
concernés donc je voyais très rassurés
sur ce sujet là etc explique que du coup
leur apportant vous aligner sur le fond
s'est satisfait mais peut-être se redire
les choses c'est important par rapport à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens avocat ou
non d'ailleurs
les avocats nés après 75 seront affiliés
au régime général et donc intégré au
système universel a compté 2025
puisque je rappelle que 2022 c'est pour
les génération 2004
comme l'a dit le rapporteur tout à
l'heure
on sait que compte tenu des études
nécessaires pour être sûr cette
profession on y est plutôt vers 24 25 26
ans est pas et pas quand on a 18 ans
donc les avocats concernés par la
réforme commenceront à cotiser dans le
système universel de retraite uniquement
à partir de cette date et il n'y aura
pas de choc de cotisation en 2025
on a justement prévu une transition sur
15 ans pour permettre aux avocats
libéraux qui seront concernés de
s'adapter au nouveau système
et si vous partager avec moi cette
préoccupation de faire que pour
l'ensemble des professions libérales
mais vous par les avocats de profession
vous connaissez bien et donc j'apprécie
votre votre propos aussi nous assurons
au travers du changement d'assiette de
cg et au travers de l'amendement que le
gouvernement a proposé hier soir en
fléchant les droits de plaidoirie
je rappelle que les doigts après les
droits de plaidoirie sont acquittées par
les justiciables en les flèches envers
la cnb la possibilité pour cette caisse
de faire une péréquation entre ce qui
vous préoccupe les cabinets qui ont des
revenus très conséquent et ceux qui ont
des revenus notamment ceux qui débutent
ou ceux qui sont sur les territoires
peut-être où il ya plus de recours à
l'aide juridictionnelle est peut-être
moins d'affaires qu'ils peuvent
présenter une forte valeur ajoutée
financière et bien il y aura une
péréquation qui sera possible qui serait
déterminé d'ailleurs par les avocats
puisque c'est eux qui détermineront
comment sais tu ce fléchage des droits
de plaidoirie sera ventilé mais le
projet doit maintenant été amendé depuis
hier soir
grâce à cet amendement qui doit
permettre à mon avis de retrouver vos
attentes donc voilà pourquoi je vous
explique ma demande de retrait est à la
fois j'espère vous avoir fait partager
la volonté du gouvernement de maintenir
les équilibres pour l'ensemble des
cabinets d'avocats
monsieur gosselin
sur le président je salue évidemment
comme tous les autres votre façon de
présider mais au-delà de ça je voulais
saluer l'intervention de notre collègue
s'il là c'est courageux ça montre aussi
qu'au sein même de la majorité des
questions se posent sur le régime
autonome des avocats et la transition et
dire comme monsieur le rapporteur
général l'a dit tout à l'heure que
l'amendement était déjà satisfait cc à
la fois vrai et faux bien sûr il l'est
dans les pures strict de votre projet
mais en réalité par rapport à l'esprit à
la volonté d'autonomie aux besoins
d'autonomie à la participation des
avocats au régime général déjà
aujourd'hui à la singularité haustrate
est en réalité à la grande pluralité des
façons d'exercer pour les avocats je
crois que la remarque qui est
sous-entendu par cet amendement est
forte
ça veut donc dire qu'aujourd'hui
réellement et au delà de ce qui vient
d'être expliquée par le ministre le
sujet des avocats n'est pas mûr encore
il faut le travailler il faut donner du
temps au temps et je crois qu'on a là en
plus c'est un amendement de la majorité
donc vous pouvez le voter sans vous
dédire et je crois qu'il ya là une
matière à réflexion et moi je rejoins
cette réflexion à la nôtre et ça vous
montre bien qu'en réalité sur tous les
bancs la question reste pendante ça
devrait vous interrogez merci moi j'ai
un collègue madame automne on en a parlé
également oui merci sur cet amendement
qui concerne les avocats parfois nous
n'avons pas les réponses
ou en tout cas des réponses parfois
contradictoires ou incomplètes sur les
bancs du gouvernement ou du rapporteur
et nous pouvons trouver sur les réseaux
sociaux des propos d'ailleurs qui ont
été tenus dans cet hémicycle je pense à
ce tweet de jean terrier qui circule
beaucoup et qui nous garantit que à
partir de 2020 2029
les avocats n'auront pour hausses de
cotisations que 5 4% 1 de hausse puisque
jusque là il n'y a pas de problème tout
ira bien mais c'est simplement à partir
de 2029 de 2029 que les choses vont
changer
d'abord petit fake news ce n'est pas 5
4% mais 5,4 points 5,4 points et donc ce
sont des pourcentages de points et non
pas 5,4 pour cent ce qui change tout le
cnpf nous explique que cela revient à 40
% d'augmentation et non pas à 5 4%
d'augmentation donc j'aimerais bien vous
interroger sur ce point monsieur le
ministre on est bien la corse c'est que
c'est une augmentation de 5,4 points sur
le pourcentage c'est pas du tout la même
chose
et deuxième chose notre collègue
attendait avec impatience les
ordonnances mais le rapporteur nous dit
que tout est clair dans l'étude d'impact
dont quelque chose que je n'arrive plus
à comprendre s'il reste qu'on arrive à
faire des projections sérieuse avec tous
les éléments ou est-ce qu'il faut
attendre les ordonnances pour faire des
projections sérieuse mais en tout cas je
crois que là ya à l'évidence une
contradiction donc quelle est la bonne
hypothèse enfin je réitère ma question
monsieur le ministre il n'ya pas
d'expropriation laquelle des retraites
mais en revanche il ya bien une
utilisation de cette caisse pour la
transition est ce que vous pouvez ici
nous garantir comme vous sembliez le
faire tout à l'heure que vous ne
toucherez pas la caisse des avocats
monsieur lui frémir
oui monsieur oui monsieur le président
effectivement on voit bien que la
question des avocats restent entièrement
posée et que ce qu'ils entendent ne les
satisfait pas et je pense que
l'excellente amendement de madame sylla
et bien va permettre de remettre le
métier sur l'ouvragé
et je suis d'accord avec mon collègue
jocelyn il ne suffit pas de dire que cet
amendement il est satisfait il est
satisfait avec les conditions que vous
avez posé mais cette période de
réflexion permet éventuellement
d'explorer d'autres solutions pour les
avocats donc je pense que c'est le bon
sens que de voter cet amendement
effectivement proposé d'ailleurs par un
membre de la majorité
et je crois que l'adoption de cet
amendement est bien remettra de la
sérénité avec cette profession qui se
sent totalement incomprise aujourd'hui
avec les propositions qui sont faites
ton que le groupe gdr tout au moins ceux
qui sont présents ici des meilleurs
voeux tron cet amendement
merci on le dira aux autres mesures
fraigne je sais pas si apprécieront les
autres endroits de groupe
monsieur petit oui j'aime beaucoup quand
les règles de trois reviennent ce dans
cet hémicycle
effectivement le 5 % sur 14 pour cent ça
fait effectivement 40% de 14 ça fait
toujours 5% de sang donc je crois je
crois que cette cette démonstration est
assez évidente
et d'ailleurs quand vous parlez je vous
rappelle que quand vous augmentez le
point
quand vous dites qu'il manque que deux
points de pim là aussi pareil ça fait
c'est pas 2 % de pipe que vous augmentez
parce que si vous prenez le même calcul
vous augmenterez de 20% 2 sur 12
merci
merci différents groupes ont pu
s'exprimer donc on va mettre voire d'un
vote à main levée cet amendement qui
fait l'objet d'avis départ aux
commissions un gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté prochaine séance cet après
midi à 15 heures suite du projet l'ouest